English subtitles were generated by AI and are for reference only.
Hello everyone, I'm Xiaojun
Today our guest is Yao Shunyu, a researcher at Google DeepMind
There are two famous Yao Shunyus in Silicon Valley
One previously worked at OpenAI, then jumped ship to Tencent to become their Chief AI Scientist
He's been on our show before
Today I've invited the other Yao Shunyu
He was previously at Anthropic
Now he's at Google DeepMind
We'll start by talking about the recent series of massive model changes
So next is my interview with Shunyu
Anthropic as a company
It's able to implement this kind of
relatively top-down mechanism
is something quite unique
But is this difficult for other model companies?
Very difficult. For example, OpenAI can't do it
And Gemini also finds it difficult
Big companies and startups
Their strategies are fundamentally different
Because for startups, what's important is making bets
I have to bet on something
I think everyone right now is basically
everyone is a surfer
Fundamentally it's a wave
Not the surfer
But anyway, it just feels like this AI thing
doesn't really require much brains
Doesn't require much brains
Really doesn't require much brains
Then what does it require?
I think in this
industry, the most important trait
is being reliable
Being detail-oriented
And taking responsibility for what you do
These are the most important traits
Aren't there two Yao Shunyus in Silicon Valley?
Why don't you first introduce yourself to everyone
And then explain to everyone
The difference between the two Yao Shunyus
Ah
Sure, yeah
So my name is Yao Shunyu
And
Obviously there's also a friend with an almost identical name (Yao Shunyu, Chief AI Scientist at Tencent, former OpenAI researcher)
Our main career paths also have some overlap (overlap)
So it might look very difficult to tell us apart
Yeah, and
I used to study physics
I did my undergrad at Tsinghua
I worked on condensed matter theory back then
Then later went to Stanford to do theoretical high-energy physics
And quantum information
and black hole-related areas
After leaving Stanford
went to Berkeley
briefly stayed for two weeks as a postdoc (postdoctoral researcher)
Then quit
and went to Anthropic
Stayed at Anthropic for a year
Around late September to early October last year
joined Gemini
Yeah, and
If everyone insists on telling us apart
I think the biggest difference is
That Shunyu, he has always been doing CS from the start
Computer science-related stuff
While I actually
In a sense, came to this halfway
Yeah, I mainly did theoretical physics before
Yeah
Are you two good friends?
You guys seemed to have known each other since college
And you were in the same year, right? (Yes)
What kind of person is he?
What kind of person are you?
Evaluate him
Evaluate yourself too (hahaha)
Yeah yeah, we knew each other since undergrad
Because we were in the same year in undergrad
At Tsinghua
But he
Of course he studied computer science from the start
So he was in that Yao Class
the computer science experimental class
And I studied physics
So I was in the Ji Class
Yeah, and later he went to Princeton
I went to Stanford
This might also be another somewhat puzzling point
Which is, it seems like in the general world
people think Stanford is where computer science people
should go
And
think Princeton is where physics people should go
But we happened to do the opposite
Haha
So that might also have caused some confusion
And we really are quite different
I think he's a much more interesting person than I am
I think I've also learned a lot from him
In the past as well
I've been able to learn things that are quite different from my own strengths
For example, he probably spends a lot of time thinking
Like in AI
He spends a lot of time thinking about
Human-AI interaction
And also some product-related things
And I think, for me,
He's a very different kind of friend
And I've also learned a lot from him
When you were in Silicon Valley
How often did you meet?
Do you still call each other frequently now?
How frequently?
We did meet quite frequently when we were in Silicon Valley
Maybe every few weeks
But it seems like we mainly met just to hang out
Hahaha
Doing what?
Well
It was really just purely for fun
Like going out for a walk
And chatting about random stuff
And sometimes having a meal
Playing cards or something like that
Right, haha, right
And after he went back
We actually still
Often call each other
What did you talk about in the most recent call?
I think it was one or two weeks ago
Ah
How did you know?
Uh, probably just
Every few months
Then we catch up a bit
Share recent updates, yeah
Has he tried multiple times to get you to join him?
Uh
Hmm
Ha
Maybe he does, I guess
But, but
I don't think it matters
It doesn't matter, hahaha
Why don't you go?
I think for myself
I
Haven't figured it out yet
Yeah, I think it's mostly my own reasons
And then
I didn't join any
Chinese companies either
And I think the main reason is
Around September or August-September last year
I think
When I left
Left Anthropic
And when deciding where to go after leaving, my biggest motivation was
I wanted to learn something different
Yeah, for me
I probably didn't consider
No, no
More seriously consider
Being able to lead a project
Or lead a project or something
I was more
At that time
More focused on prioritizing learning something new
So that's why I chose to go to Gemini, right
I noticed
You two are always being compared and discussed together
Is it more of a bother or more enjoyable for you?
I don't really feel anything about it
And
Because I'm not really someone who pays attention to social media
So I really don't feel anything about it
Yeah
Because Shunyu
He said last year
AI has entered the second half
Entered the second half
This became a very famous viewpoint
What do you think of today's AI
What stage is it at?
Can you give it a definition?
Yeah, for me
I might
Not see so clearly what the first half means
What the second half means
Or rather, this definition
Has never been particularly clear to me
For me
AI has indeed entered a stage
Where I think
Everyone has started to worry less about one thing
Whether AI can do it
And more about whether the problem itself is well-defined
Yeah, I think this is a huge difference.
For example, I think a year ago
or maybe early last year
at that time
I was at Anthropic
and what everyone was worried about was like, 'Hey,'
OpenAI's reasoning is so strong
do we have a chance to catch up?
and how likely are we to surpass them?
Everyone was still very worried about this.
I think now, at least among
at least among Gemini, OpenAI, and Anthropic, these three
I don't think any of them
is really worried about not catching up.
Mm-hmm.
And I think what might be harder for everyone now
is
figuring out what to actually do.
This is something that
I think is
is a bet
but also
I think it's also
something that requires a lot of human insight. Yeah.
So that also means model capabilities have been leveled out.
Right? They've become homogenized
commoditized.
So there's not a huge difference between the models.
In terms of good versus bad, there's not a huge difference.
But they need to differentiate.
I think from the actual user experience,
you can feel the differences between these three companies' models.
But the hard part is
in the past, you could see this difference on paper too.
What do you mean by 'on paper'?
'On paper' means, like, publicly available
there are many kinds of benchmarks
these standardized measurement frameworks.
And for example, people used to look at SWE-bench
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you could look at SWE-bench.
And for math, back then people would compare things like
simpler ones
AIME
and harder ones like IMO. Back then it felt like
you could tell just from the numbers.
'Hey, this model seems stronger at reasoning'
'that model seems stronger at coding'
'that model is stronger at this.'
Now, on paper, everyone is actually pretty close.
And when you look at the numbers on paper
like looking at SWE-bench
you'll find, 'Hey,'
it seems like the best is only
maybe one percentage point
or two percentage points
better than the not-so-good ones, but actually everyone is around 80%.
A slightly higher number around there
or a slightly lower one is mostly just noise
It's mainly just noise
rather than signal.
Yeah. But on the other hand,
in actual usage, people can still
experience the differences.
I think, mm-hmm.
From what I personally know,
Claude is still the more general-purpose
in terms of this tool-using
agent, the best-performing one.
And in pure coding
maybe Codex has caught up a bit recently
narrowing the gap a little.
And Gemini
might be better at pure reasoning
and in some more everyday usage scenarios
it might still be better for now.
And then in
in coding and agents, it's still in a state of
catching up.
Mm-hmm. These capabilities—
are they deliberately choosing which direction to prioritize
or is it simply a matter of good versus bad?
Is it a capability issue or a prioritization issue?
I think
there is actually an element of prioritization involved.
Especially in the past,
it was mainly about prioritization.
When everyone could see the differences on paper,
prioritization was definitely the dominant factor.
Because maybe
like Claude
has always valued this tool-use capability more.
Mm-hmm.
And including coding.
So
maybe OpenAI also placed a lot of emphasis on reasoning for a while.
Yeah, and of course now they're starting to focus on coding too.
So back then, prioritization definitely accounted for most of it.
Because if you're more willing to prioritize something
it means you can spend more effort
building the right infrastructure.
the right infrastructure
building the right data
and especially data
it's something that
in a sense
takes a lot of time and effort
right
so back then, it was definitely driven by willingness
but at this point
I think both factors are at play
because
well, on paper, everyone looks pretty similar
and even if you do some
more internal testing
the numbers become
not that different
and then the harder thing becomes
how you define your problem
define the behavior you want
mm-hmm
and when this thing
isn't defined very clearly
a lot of the model differences actually come from things
that you wouldn't even imagine
right
by 'things you wouldn't imagine,' I mean
I mean, things you wouldn't imagine
if you ask me now
it's hard for me to give you a very clear answer
maybe after some time, looking back
I'll be able to give a clear answer
but I can give an example
of something you wouldn't imagine
like, if we go back
maybe one, two, or even three years
back then, if you went online
to collect pre-training data
you'd see models learning to write code
of course, there wasn't this agentic way of writing code back then
it was just writing a piece of code (mm-hmm)
and you'd find that
models wrote code very well
but back then, people didn't know why
but the unexpected reason behind this might be
if you just randomly collect from the web
without any data filtering
naturally
the quality of code data would be a bit higher than others
because if you look at web pages
you'll find
GitHub's quality
is significantly higher than other normal web pages
before we get into today's topic
I'd like to talk about
some recent news about our models
you see
everyone's been talking about OpenClaw recently
mm-hmm
as a frontline researcher
what do you think of this new product form
what discussions are happening around you
what's interesting is
I feel like the discussion outside the industry
seems more intense than inside the industry
oh, no one inside the industry is talking about it?
people inside are talking about it
but I think for industry insiders
it's not really, um
a particularly surprising thing
oh, what do you mean
like, maybe inside the company
some people have already done similar experiments
or demos like this
it's just that it wasn't packaged as a product
and seriously marketed
polished and launched
right, and
of course, the reality is
if you look at OpenClaw
the earliest version of the code on GitHub
actually, that code was
in a sense
not particularly clean
but I think what's important is
it showed everyone this possibility
mm-hmm, and after showing this possibility
the OpenClaw
author himself joined OpenAI
and then
then probably these model labs
or some larger startups will catch up quickly
and polish this into a truly usable product
mm-hmm (right), so I understand
actually, before OpenClaw was released
people at Google were already working on this
it just hadn't been released yet
because big companies have longer processes
right, my, my, my
at least personally
that's the impression I've gotten
What we're seeing is exactly that. Right.
So behind this product form, similar to OpenClaw,
what does that inherently tell us?
At this point in early this year,
I think, actually,
technically speaking,
it doesn't really prove much.
I mean, this OpenClaw product,
of course it relies on many things the model can do,
but those capabilities
weren't actually only ready
by early this year.
I think maybe last year,
like when Opus released 4.5 (Claude series),
and then, and then...
of course back then, Opus was actually ahead of OpenAI and Gemini 3
in terms of tool use capabilities.
So I think at that point,
doing this thing,
it was already something you could demonstrate.
And actually, it
didn't blow up immediately upon release.
It only went viral some time after the launch.
Hmm.
So,
for me personally,
technically it's not really
not really
something so surprising.
It's a natural overflow of model capabilities.
Right, right, right, I'd say so.
But I think
the surprise for everyone might be
that perhaps nobody had realized this before.
It made everyone realize this could actually be done.
Realize what?
Realized that
you can, like,
let the model do very...
I mean,
you can control many different models
and do many different things,
and then aggregate all of that,
and after aggregating,
do this kind of very, very, very long-horizon task.
This kind of work.
I think maybe
previously, people hadn't
widely reached a consensus on this.
This thing
showed everyone this kind of possibility.
You see, what went viral early last year was Manus,
and what went viral early this year is OpenClaw.
So from Manus to OpenClaw,
what changed?
Is it a change in model capabilities,
or a change in the product?
This is also something I've never really understood.
Hmm.
Like,
What is the qualitative difference between Manus and OpenClaw?
It's something
I actually haven't quite figured out myself.
To be honest, haha.
OK.
Hmm, like,
or in other words,
maybe OpenClaw went viral,
but if you were to ask me retroactively,
why Manus couldn't do this,
I don't understand why Manus couldn't do it.
Maybe they just didn't get it right.
But you see,
whether it's Manus or OpenClaw,
they both chose to sell.
Manus was sold to Meta (Note: This acquisition has since been revoked; our program was recorded before the revocation).
OpenClaw was sold to OpenAI.
What does this phenomenon tell us?
Why did they both sell?
I think, hmm,
my own feeling is that for something
to survive long-term,
it still needs to have some moats.
The moat is the model.
I think
at least for now,
many moats are on the model side.
But whether product-side moats will emerge in the future,
I think that's hard to say.
Because everyone...
This is all an age-old topic in the market.
Many people talk about this.
Things like data flywheels and such.
For now,
I don't think there's any scenario
that has truly formed a data flywheel.
Even purely AI-native application scenarios.
I think currently, besides agentic coding,
other than writing code,
there's no scenario that is truly AI-native.
became hugely successful
because in a sense
chatbots are actually an extension of search
A chatbot is an extension of search
Right, that's why it's not independent of search
It's because
because think about it
the most common way people interact with chatbots is
I have a question
and they ask the chatbot
and that's essentially what search has always done
But what it offers
something far better than search is
it becomes very interactive (交互的)
It has interactivity
You can ask follow-up questions
and it can even help you summarize
some of the information you get through it
helping you distill it into
a condensed answer to your question
Right, this is something search could never give you before
Mm-hmm (right)
But of course it's not exactly the same need
But in terms of demand
from a broad demand perspective
it's fairly similar to the demand that existed before
Manus and OpenClaw
I think they're the most famous wrappers right now
But wrappers ended up being sold to model companies (Note: Meta's acquisition of Manus was later reversed; our show was recorded before the reversal)
Doesn't that show that wrappers
still can't escape the grip of model companies
The escape velocity isn't enough
It's not fast enough, is it
I think
I think for wrappers to survive in the current environment
there are two approaches I can roughly imagine
One approach is what you just said
Escape fast enough
That is, my growth is fast enough
that by the time model companies catch on
I've already captured significant user mindshare
And when model companies catch up to your product
by that time
I've already evolved my own model
I think Cursor is trying to take this path (mm-hmm)
So Cursor, in this AI-native scenario
is pretty much the fastest-growing startup
I can think of
Even a company like that
is feeling a strong sense of crisis right now
How strong is that sense of crisis
Anyway, my feeling is that for Cursor
its relationship with Anthropic right now
has entered a very delicate phase
It's like
They used to be close, seamless partners
Anthropic provided the model
Cursor provided the product
Later Anthropic developed Claude Code itself
Claude Code has become very successful
And then
Cursor is now trying to build its own model
So Cursor is working hard training its Composer
So
I don't even think we need to talk about the future
It's already happening right now
They're already in a fairly competitive relationship (mm-hmm)
If they lose in this competition
I think it would be quite problematic
Because when it comes to coding
when it comes to coding
at its core it's essentially
a professional need
serving professional users
It's a productivity tool
A common scenario with productivity tools is
winner takes all
I think this applies whether to Cursor
or to Anthropic
or for any company doing coding
It's probably something they're all quite worried about
Mm-hmm (right)
So that's what I was saying
That's one path
(It has to be fast) That is, you grow fast enough
You grow like crazy before anyone even thinks about acquiring you
just grow wildly
By the time they want to acquire you
you're big enough
Another way is for the market to be small enough
so small that model companies can't even be bothered
I think Midjourney is exactly that example
That's it
The market is so small that perhaps
even though you could say Gemini could make an effort
to replicate what Midjourney does
It might take some effort
some money
some data to pull it off
but it's small enough
To the point where
Gemini probably wouldn't want to spend much time on that
It's beneath them
Right, haha
I think that might also be a way to survive
Yeah
So even Cursor
hasn't escaped the model's grasp today
Has anyone successfully escaped?
For the big ones, I haven't seen any so far
For smaller ones, maybe Midjourney is an example
Of course there must be other examples
I just haven't seen them yet
Right, smaller ones
I think there will be
There will be examples
Does Lovart count?
I think they have a shot
They have a shot
Anyway, you can't do the general-purpose thing
I think this is something the founder has to decide
Whether you want to bet on something big with a one-in-ten-thousand chance of survival
and swing for the fences
Or go with a one-percent chance of survival
and lock down something small first
If it were you
What would you choose?
Hahahaha
If it were me
Deep down I'd definitely want to swing for the fences
But honestly
I genuinely think
You can't get there overnight
So if it were me
I'd choose to secure a small win first
But I'd pick a small one with huge upside potential
Why do you think OpenAI acquired OpenClaw?
Why did Meta want to buy Manus (Note: Meta's acquisition of Manus was later revoked; our show was recorded before the revocation)
Why doesn't Google acquire anyone?
Oh, Google did acquire someone
Google bought the Windsurf team
Okay, Windsurf
Yeah
I don't get it
Haha
What do you mean you don't get it?
Honestly, it's just that
I don't get it
I think
I think Meta's acquisition of Manus
I think for them
The biggest benefit was
If
aside from how much they spent
The biggest benefit was gaining a really strong
product team in Asia
What does being in Asia signify?
Because
I think on one hand
Obviously everyone knows
China's AI talent pool is still quite deep
Although perhaps currently in terms of technology
Purely from a technical standpoint
Chinese AI hasn't really caught up with the US yet
But
Obviously there are many talented AI people in China
Whether in pure technology or in product
In terms of product, I think China essentially
has better talent than the US
Right, so for them
I think Manus became a
foothold in Singapore
So they can attract some
For example, from China
Or from Singapore or East Asian talent
And I actually haven't fully figured out
How important this product itself is to Meta
Or in other words
Why couldn't Meta just build this product themselves?
But whether it's Manus or OpenClaw
They were in fact born from outside teams
Why
weren't they built by this group of Silicon Valley researchers?
Have you thought about that?
Yeah, I think
Hmm, for me this question
Actually
I think once a company gets big
Its burden gets bigger too
Like, I might be a researcher
and we can build something really
interesting-looking
very distinctive products
But once I make that product public
There's a ton of responsibility that comes with it
First, you can't just launch this product
and tell all your users
You need to go buy another computer to do this
Otherwise it might gain access to everything on your computer
All the permissions—
and crash your system
Mm-hmm
So for a big company
Take Google, for example
Google would never release a product like this
Right? Mm-hmm
So it takes a lot of time to polish the product
And you have to make sure
there are no legal risks
and that it won't damage your brand with users
Plus,
if you ship it
you probably have to allocate
some relatively fixed resources
to serve this model
or serve this
product line
So yeah, yeah
For big companies
I think there's quite a lot of burden
But for individuals
it doesn't matter
I mean, it's an open-source project anyway
So what if my code is terrible
Come help me write it
Right? Hahaha, yeah
I think whether it's Manus or OpenClaw
they actually point to a direction
which is
this is also a possible narrative for 2026
What are your thoughts on 2026
and what are your expectations
I think there are really so many possibilities
And for me
in terms of model capabilities
I think
Models— I sometimes really love saying this slogan
which is that models should achieve
train with finite context, use as infinite context (finite in training, infinite in use)
In other words
you use this limited
this context length (context window) to train it
but in usage, it can use a very, very long
even nearly infinite context length
I think this
has a chance of being realized this year
And once this is achieved
I think it will unlock many new applications
because, to give the simplest example
you could potentially let this model
interact with you continuously
and continuously receive your information
And as it runs
it will continuously evaluate the current context and your conversation
and possibly discard information it deems unimportant
And then it becomes
the personal assistant everyone dreams of
Yeah, I think technically speaking
I think this will
definitely be realized this year no matter what
But of course, of course
I think what people haven't reached consensus on yet is
how to technically achieve this
Mm-hmm
Obviously there are many technical paths
But I think right now it's more about
trying to see which path can work
There might be several paths that all work
Then we'll have to test them experimentally
under common user scenarios
to see which path is the most efficient
Yeah, I think we're more at this stage right now
rather than a stage where no one has ideas
Everyone has ideas
but we need to figure out which idea is the right one
Standing here in Q1 2026 as
a frontline researcher
do you think the pace of model improvement is slowing down
I think not at all (not at all) I think not at all
How does its velocity curve compare to '25
and what's changed from '24
Mm, it's hard to say quantitatively
because you need to give me a standard
before I can quantitatively tell you
because if the standard you give is, like
I just look at some Benchmark
like, say, SWE-bench
how many points it gains each month
then this will definitely slow down
because by definition
this Benchmark maxes out at 100%
Mm-hmm
so the closer you get
the slower it definitely gets
but this doesn't necessarily mean
that users feel the model's capability growth has slowed
because going from 50% to 60%
it might feel like, hey
that's a bit better
but quite possibly
For example, from 70% to 75%
It found that the gains are even greater than from 50% to 60%
Mm-hmm
That's entirely possible
If it's from 80% to 90%
Or 90% to 100%, the difference would feel even more significant
Not necessarily
Because maybe past
Maybe around 80% to 90%
Users wouldn't notice any difference
It might even get worse
You said it doesn't get slower at all
Based on what criteria?
I think it's based on
my personal feeling as a researcher
Like
My personal impression is
the model's ability to learn things is getting stronger and stronger
It used to take a lot of effort
to get the model to learn to do something
But now it probably doesn't require that much effort
The most important thing is
you need to clearly define the problem
and figure out how to build the right data (Mm-hmm)
Of course, data
Data is broader now
including environments and such
And
the rest
often seems to fall into place naturally
Right
Why is the learning ability getting stronger?
The model's learning ability has improved
I think maybe on one hand
There could be many reasons
But I think one reason is pre-training
Actually, over the past few months
I think it has been getting stronger
Pre-training
Right, right
Model pre-training
has actually gotten stronger in the past few months (Mm-hmm)
I think this might be
somewhat controversial in a sense
Because a few months ago
I think
many people were already discussing whether
this Scaling Law
had reached its limit
Mm-hmm
My experience is that it hasn't
And my feeling is
in the next four months
I don't see any signs of it ending either
Mm-hmm
Why do people think it's reaching its limit?
I think, well
I-I-I
obviously don't know
why people think it's reached its limit
Because I myself don't feel it's reached its limit
But my guess would be
When someone thinks a pattern has reached its limit
it's basically
one of these two situations
Ah
One situation is
they feel the applicable range of this pattern has reached its limit
Ah, maybe
Maybe
Fundamentally speaking
Scaling Law
simply can't extend infinitely
which could be true
But this is just a guess
That is, this person might feel that
the applicable range of this pattern has reached its limit
Another possibility is
this person feels that
this pattern
one of its conditions can no longer be met
For example, they feel that data has already hit a wall
Then I simply haven't extended it further
Another possibility
But actually there's a third possibility
The third possibility is that
there's a bug somewhere in their work
that they haven't noticed themselves
So they think it's reached its limit
Oh
From my perspective
From my observation
I think
probably the vast majority of people who hit a wall
it's because of the third reason
It's because there's a bug
What kind of bug?
I think
There are many possible kinds of bugs
For example, one possibility is
When you're working on Scaling Laws
Some scientific assumptions weren't quite right
For example, what kind of token horizon you choose
That is, for each model size, what kind of
expected training data volume you pick
And then this amount of data
Where this data comes from
And then
It's possible that these more scientific choices
weren't made clearly
That's one possibility
But I think there's another possibility, which is
there's simply a bug
Actually, I don't think this is surprising in the industry
Many times
Fixing a single bug
The progress it brings
is far greater than some fancy tricks
Right
And of course, there are other situations
These two examples I just gave
are situations I've seen quite often
So how do you deal with bugs
How do you solve bug problems
I think, right
I feel like this is more of a mindset issue
Because when you encounter a bug
If you think it can't be fixed
You'll say we've hit a wall
When you encounter a bug
I think, oh
This can definitely be fixed
Then you'll feel like we haven't hit a wall yet
Because everyone definitely encounters bugs
I think, I think
This might be like what you said
That is
There are some things that are more about belief
But for me
A more important thing is the working system
That is, when something
is different from what you predicted
Can you systematically rule out various possibilities
I think this is a very important thing
Mmhmm
This
is something I think Gemini and Anthropic do well
That is
Especially in pre-training
That is, when behavior at a certain scale
might be different from what you imagined
People can design reasonable
what we call ablation experiments (消融实验)
reasonable experiments like this
can help you see
test whether some of your
imagined possible factors
are actually the real factors
I think this
systematic approach to problem-solving is the key
Mmhmm
You think
Model capabilities can still improve
Then its driving force
Data and compute
Algorithms
Which do you think is the main driving force
I think they all contribute
But in a sense
Data and compute are two things
that are actually very strongly correlated
Data and compute, mmhmm
Right, because
When your compute goes up
you'll naturally attract more data
When data goes up
you'll naturally need more compute
Right, and then
For algorithms, I think
Algorithmic progress often has a phase transition
That is, there's a phase
where you haven't figured out what to do at all
At that stage, algorithms are extremely critical
Because when you haven't figured out what to do at all
you might have no way to scale up at all
And then you might get stuck there
But at a certain point
you might discover
the most important thing in the algorithm
Then it might suddenly go from
completely impossible to possible
And then after that, algorithmic improvements
are more of a gradual improvement
That is
It might improve your computational efficiency
or the efficiency of using data
Right, and then
Let me give an example
For example, from the perspective of language model pre-training
Then this leap in algorithms
Well
I mean, the development of the Transformer
But after the Transformer was discovered
It's been mostly gradual and smooth
Improving its efficiency
Or your use of data
Or the efficiency of compute usage has been improving
Right
So the current drivers are compute and data
I think within the relatively clear frameworks we have now
The main drivers are compute and data
By clear framework, I mean
For example, pre-training and post-training
Whether it's post-training based on reinforcement learning
Or based on supervised learning
That is, post-training with supervised learning
For example, within these two relatively clear
paradigms (范式)
Indeed, compute and data are the main drivers
But it's undeniable
That in some other directions, the driving factors might be different
Hmm, what do you mean?
To give a simple example
For instance, multimodal generation
Hmm
Well
I think it's probably something that, algorithmically speaking
Hasn't been fully figured out yet
So that's still a scientific problem
That hasn't been solved yet
Right
But language is no longer a scientific problem
Natural language generation
I think, for now
Before this technical approach hits a wall
I think it's relatively clear scientifically
But in terms of engineering
There's still so, so, so much to be done
How much more do you think pre-training can improve?
Improving model capabilities through pre-training
How much more
How much further can it go
Can we expect
That's just how people are
I mean, when you haven't hit the wall, you
Don't actually know how long the road is
What I can
What I can see is that we haven't hit the wall yet
But I don't know when we'll hit it either
If I really had to estimate a timeline
As I just said
I think four months
The next four months will still see progress
But in the AI field
No one can predict what happens after four months
Hmm, so over the past few months
When you look at pre-training and model capabilities
You're still very excited
Is this the general mindset and state around you?
I think so
Is this within a small environment at Google
Or in the entire Silicon Valley environment
I think it's hard to say for all of Silicon Valley
Because Silicon Valley is too big a place
People working on products might be excited about products
Right, for product people
What excites them most might be something like OpenClaw
Hmm
But for people working on models
It's probably
That we get more excited about this kind of model progress
Hmm
I think
Uh
For people working on models
Is excitement a consensus?
Over the past four months
I personally think so
Oh, I personally think so
At least within the circle I have access to
I think at
Anthropic and Google, people
Or at Gemini, people are probably thinking more about
How our AI will keep progressing
And soon we'll be replaced
After being replaced, what should we do?
Haha, rather than worrying about what to do when models hit a wall
Hahaha
Speaking of which
Why
Over the past few months
Coding has been developing the fastest
Why is this the case?
I think the coding scenario
First of all, coding itself
Hasn't just been developing the fastest over the past few months
I think coding itself
Actually
From Claude 3.5 (new)
Or some people out there called it Claude 3.6 (yeah)
After that
It's been in a state of rapid development ever since
And I think
That was early last year
Or the end of the year before
That was October of the year before last
October of the year before last
Yeah, yeah
It should be, maybe October or November
But around that time
From then on
I've been in a state of rapid development
I think the coding scenario has
Two biggest advantages
The first advantage is its reward signal (回馈信号)
That is, its feedback signal
Is very well-defined
Because
For example, if you
For example, something like a software engineer (软件工程师) task
Often the situation is
I need to write some code
To implement a feature
A feature
(Yeah) This feature needs certain inputs
And produces certain outputs
This is something very easy to
Very easy to test
So its feedback signal is very clear
Your input and output match up
Then it means your implementation is successful
If not, then it's unsuccessful (Yeah)
But this is just one example
In coding-related work
There are many, many
Many such well-defined feedback signals
And another big advantage is
Coding data has a very natural foundation
That foundation is GitHub
GitHub has aggregated over the past few, roughly
Decades
A lot of high-quality code written by many excellent programmers
And starting from that code
You can build a tremendous number of environments
I think these two things, from a model perspective
Are why coding can be done very well
Of course, I think from a product perspective
There's another reason
Which is that coding
The demand for this product
Is in a sense
Relatively singular
It's not like when you build something like a social media app
Or a game
Where everyone might have different tastes
And it might be hard
To satisfy everyone's needs
Then you might need recommendation algorithms
But with coding
The good thing is that excellent programmers writing code
Actually have fairly similar styles
What kind of style
Clean and concise
Yeah, right, good code is
(Not messy) There are some shared standards
For example, like you said
The code is concise
Structurally clear
Suitable for future development
And has reasonable abstractions
And of course many other standards
But I think good programmers tend to have
A fairly consensus-driven standard
On this matter
So from a product perspective
It actually makes the coding product much simpler
In your current work
What percentage of code do you write with Claude Code
How many times more productive does it make you
You just asked a question that almost got me fired
Google doesn't allow using Claude Code
Hahahahaha, oh right
I think, for me
A conservative estimate
Maybe 90% of the code is model-generated
But it might be
I need to spend a lot of time reviewing the code
To see if it's written appropriately
Written reasonably
Whether it's really what I wanted it to write
And I think after having AI-assisted tools
The most important thing about writing code
Has become
How you design it
How you design the logic of your code
And which files it needs to interact with
Files to associate with
And what things need to be done
And you need to give the model
Maybe provide some reasonable context
I mean, like
For example, this code
You can use it as a reference (参考) to take a look
Right, actually outputting code
I think models are way more capable than humans
So for me
If you actually count
How many lines of code I wrote by hand
How many lines of code the model wrote
I'd say conservatively, the model wrote over 90%
If not conservative, maybe 99% or 100%
The remaining 10% is what it can't write
Or why you didn't let it write
Conservatively, 90%
Giving myself some credit
Hahaha
I think what it can't write
And the part I can write is becoming less and less
Less and less and less
What was it like in the past
It was what it couldn't write
I think
Very early on, maybe about a year and a half ago
At that time
To be honest, on the market
Only Claude was able to
Actually write this kind of software engineering code
At that time
You could still feel many flaws in the model
For example
Sometimes when it wrote code
It would only focus on this one file
It wouldn't pay much attention to multiple
The relationships between multiple files
And if, say, a class
Its definition was buried many layers deep
Or it wasn't directly nested in this
This direct tree structure
The model probably couldn't find it
Now I think this is happening less and less
Hehe
Really less and less
As a researcher
Your programming workload
How many times that of the past
Because from the perspective of writing code
It's quite hard to quantify this
But if we talk about, say, running experiments
And the efficiency of implementing ideas
I think compared to a year or even a year and a half ago
It could be 20 or even 50 times faster
Right, because models have really become
It can be pretty insane
You can open several at the same time
And you have several ideas
And test them simultaneously
And sometimes even
The model can help you monitor some experiments
Monitor some results and stuff
So
It's really quite a significant efficiency boost
Right, but
If we talk about personal working hours
I feel like it has made my working hours longer
Why is that
It's just that
Because development speed has increased
The more you try, the more you want to try
There are more and more ideas to try
So it feels like before, you might have had this situation
You have something
Like this file
You haven't seen it before
You might not quite understand it yourself
Then you'd definitely have to spend time finding that person
And you'd schedule
That person, maybe a few hours later
But now it's not like that
You just see this file
You don't understand it, just ask Claude or Gemini
Gemini might tell you the result in five seconds
And you just keep going
Hahaha, so in terms of working hours
I feel like working hours have actually gotten longer
And the intensity has increased too
Well, Google isn't that Google anymore
Is that so
Not that
Google where you can coast along
Not that work-life balance Google
I feel like in the GenAI (生成式人工智能) field
No one can just coast along
Hahaha
So what hours are you keeping these days
I usually start around 9 in the morning
Get to the office at 9
At 9 AM, I might first get up and check emails
And look at the experiments from the night before
Then get to the office around 10
And then at night
If I'm alone in the US
I might stay until around 10 or 11
Of course, if my family is here
If my wife is here
I might go home a bit earlier
But at home I'd be working anyway
So I think in the GenAI field
No one is just lying around
Unless
You've completely lost interest in technology
And have no ambition for yourself
Then no one would care if you just lay there
But I think most people are quite self-driven
They just want to do it themselves, right
Do you think other fields
Will have more of these Claude Code moments
Where will the next explosion happen after coding
You asked a good question
If I could see it clearly
I might have gone out to start a company already
Hahahaha
Right, but but
It's true that besides coding
We can already see
That many
Other directions are already having a big impact
But if we only talk about those directions
They might not be a good
market direction
Because
Coding is special in that
It itself is
A very large market
But if you look at some other directions
They might not be
Such a large market
For example
Some people say the next direction is
This kind of
AI-generated content or something
But AI-generated content
How big is that market
Right
I think
If you say this content
Is for people to consume
Then people have limited time
No matter how much content you generate
People's time is only 24 hours a day
Right
Unless it completely replaces people
Like replacing TV
Then that would be another story
Like the Vision Pro that came out before
But that would be
A bigger story
So I think
Besides coding
Everyone is still looking for
The next big market
And if there is one
I think there will be
But it's just
Not necessarily that big
I think the most likely one might be
This kind of interactive education
Or maybe
You said coding is not a direction for you
Because coding itself is already very big
Yeah, it's already a huge market
Do you think AI researchers
How should we treat coding
Should we use coding to validate our ideas
Or should we make coding itself the end goal
I think there are two types of people
One type is
They genuinely want to make coding better
Another type is
They want to use coding
As a means to validate AI capabilities
I think both are fine
Both directions are fine
But I think
The people who genuinely want to make coding better
They need to think more about products
And the people who want to validate AI capabilities
They need to think more about
How to build better benchmarks
Right
I think both directions are very meaningful
Just their focus is different
Do you think
The current state of AI research
Is more like
A gold rush
Or more like
A scientific revolution
I think it's a bit of both
Like those things AI
There are many things that AI actually can't easily do
But conversely, humans might do better
For example, being a product manager
To be honest, I think
Being a good product manager
Is something I currently can't figure out
How to train AI to do
Why is that
There's no standard
There's no standard (no metric)
Like what makes a good product
I can't really figure it out
There's no very objective standard
You have to build it and let people use it
Only then do you know it's good
Then everyone will say it's good
Right, I think
That's something with very unclear feedback signals
Then I don't know how to train AI to do that
Right
When will programmers be completely replaced
Will there be such a day
Mm-hmm
I think that day will come
But it won't come all at once
It won't be like programmers are all still there
And after one night
The next day all programmers are fired
It won't be like that
It will definitely be a gradual process
But
Everyone can already see this gradual process now
Because some companies have already started laying people off
Right, I think
In a sense
AI is a
Of course it's a very good thing
But from another perspective
It might also be
A very unfortunate thing
That AI is a very centralized technology
It will make a small number of people stronger
But will make most people lose
Their unique value
Right, so I think
For traditional software engineering
The final result might be
Now 1/1000 of the people do the work of everyone in the past
Earning 100 times the current salary
Then what advice do you have for programmers
I think
Haha, I think maybe
Embrace new things
I think that's very important
I think
One very important thing for future programmers might be
How to effectively collaborate with AI
Mm-hmm, like
There are many things that AI might do
Not that well
Like how to
Reasonably design an implementation plan for something
And how to design it
So that it might align with the company's
Future development
Those kinds of things
You might have a hard time telling a model
To make it understand these things
Those things might still need humans to do
But maybe things like specific
Very specific
Like the work many programmers did in the past
Where your manager tells you to implement this plan
And give it to me by next Friday
I think that kind of work
Might not exist in the future
Then what kind of programmers would be in that 1/1000
What are their traits
1/1000 is just a figurative number
I really don't know if it would be 1/1000
Or 1/10,000
Or 1/100,000
Or maybe 1%
Don't be so pessimistic
I'm a famous pessimist
So don't take it too seriously
And
I think
Good programmers in the future
First, technically speaking
They will definitely be very strong
Because if you're technically weak
There's no reason
Why AI can't replace you
But being technically strong might not be the only thing
It won't be a necessary condition
It might be a sufficient condition
Another thing I think will be very important
is that you have to understand how your part of the work
fits into a large organization or a big company
how to
how to adapt and integrate into it (Mm-hmm)
This might also be an important thing
Mm-hmm, and
And of course there might be many other things
For example
whether this person's planning ability is strong enough
If their planning ability is strong
they can definitely take this big
very complex thing
and break it down into many relatively smaller things
and hand them over to different AIs to do
But right now these three abilities seem important
Things that AI might not be able to fully do yet
doesn't mean it won't be able to in six months
Maybe in six months you come ask me
I find that the last thing AI can already do
Then only two things remain
Another six months later
Maybe the remaining two can also be done
Then maybe my answer would become more pessimistic
So
No one can predict what will happen in six months
I can only speak from the current perspective
That past Spring Festival
Another thing many people paid attention to was Seedance
Will Seedance make Google anxious
I think actually
Possibly yes
But this anxiety
Hasn't reached me yet
Maybe it gives the Google DeepMind
team responsible for multimodal generation
some pressure
But if you ask me
I think
I might not think they have much to be anxious about
Like I think
It doesn't reflect any paradigm shift
More importantly, I think ByteDance
whether it's the product effect
or possibly in terms of data and such
These details are done very very well
I think indeed
ByteDance has historically had
a relatively strong advantage in multimodal generation
But I think at least personally
I haven't experienced
that it's a paradigm shift
Then maybe
It's not enough to make everyone very anxious
Right but there is definitely pressure
Right
Does Seedance's product capability come from model capability
Or product capability
I haven't worked
At ByteDance
So I don't
know the specific details
But if you ask me to guess
I think the model probably accounts for the majority
Mm-hmm
What does good model capability come from
Comes from data
Because there probably isn't fundamental innovation in algorithms
I think algorithms
First of all because multimodal belongs to
what we just said, still belongs to that
scientific problem
Multimodal generation belongs to scientific problems
Right, multimodal generation
Still belongs to a relatively scientific problem (Has multimodal understanding been solved)
Compared to generation it's definitely more systematic
Has a more systematic understanding
But compared to text tokens
Definitely still not that
The paradigm isn't that fixed yet
I think in generation it might be
Because it's still something
where the paradigm hasn't been fixed
Maybe each company uses somewhat different techniques
big or small differences
And um right now we can mostly just see
In terms of effects
Maybe ByteDance and Google DeepMind are
The two that do it better
Mm-hmm, so it might also come from details
Done better
Right if you ask me to guess
I would guess data
Data
If you ask me to guess I'd guess data but
I haven't worked at ByteDance either
So I'm just guessing blindly haha (Mm-hmm)
What do you think about Wu Yonghui going from Google to ByteDance (ByteDance large model team Seed lead)
Who am I to judge haha
To evaluate Yonghui I think I think
Of course, I haven't worked with
Yonghui in the past,
so
actually
I can't really give a very good assessment
or an objective evaluation
But I think after I joined Gemini,
I saw more of Yonghui's good side
I think, by looking at him,
sneaking a peek at his past code commits
and the projects he's led,
my feeling is that he's one of the few people I've met at such a high level
and also very senior
yet still has very strong technical skills
I think that's extremely rare
So I think
I think
I'm probably not yet at the level to evaluate Yonghui
at that level
But if you ask me
I think Yonghui is extremely strong
You say, taking a snapshot in Q1 2026
Do you think the capability gap between Chinese and US models
is widening or narrowing?
How far apart are they?
I think
Um
If we take a snapshot right now
and look at the development trends over the past year
or the past year and a half
Obviously
the gap between China and the US is getting smaller and smaller
But whether this gap will eventually close completely
or even if China surpasses the US
I think that's an open question
I think for Chinese AI researchers
and research institutions, it's also an opportunity
And
I think one very real thing is
that
China is indeed at a significant disadvantage in terms of actual compute resources
It's at a big disadvantage
But this significant disadvantage
may have actually forced out some interesting things
For example, Chinese model companies
are actually quite good at distilling from others
Right
Recently Dario (Anthropic Co-founder and CEO) called out three companies for distilling from them
I think distillation itself
is actually an open secret
But I think there are different ways to approach distillation
There's brute-force distillation and smart distillation
two different approaches
Um
What do you mean by brute-force distillation?
To give the simplest example of brute-force distillation:
It's
taking a bunch of tokens generated by Claude
and forcibly training on them
If you do something like this
I feel
First, it's not very ethical from a business standpoint
And intellectually, it's rather foolish
Because the companies doing this
essentially
demonstrate one thing
they don't even know what they want to do
The only thing they can do is copy others
and make their model
look a bit better on the benchmarks
Right, but essentially it shows that
they don't even know what they should be doing
That's brute-force distillation
But
actually, distillation also involves some very interesting scientific questions
For example, is there a possibility that
Just a random example
Like, could it be that
in my process of generating
my own training data pipeline
I use other models as assistants
Or the answers generated by my own model
use other models as their evaluators
This is actually, I think, commercially
a bit of a gray area
But from a technical perspective, it's quite interesting
Because if you think about it, in a sense
Chinese labs may have become
pioneers in Multi-Agent (multi-agent) training
Oh
And it's true Multi-Agent
Because if they use models from different companies
with these smarter approaches
and integrate them into a single training system
each model's distribution might be very different
The distribution of their language is very different
This is true Multi-Agent
It might be more so than
for example, using several Geminis together
It's something more technically interesting
So I think, for me, the distillation of intelligence
I don't know, commercially
whether it'll end up being clearly wrong
or clearly right
But technically it's actually quite interesting
Which companies are you referring to with these two types of distillation?
Can we bleep out the names in post-production?
(Sure) Hahahaha
First of all, I haven't worked in a Chinese lab（实验室）
So I don't know exactly who
But my feeling is
XXX
probably used hard distillation
And XXX might have done hard distillation before
But later they probably gradually tried
to shift toward soft distillation
I think it's fairly obvious
The one that probably distills less is ByteDance
I feel like ByteDance's model
is still quite distinctive
Hmm, what makes it distinctive?
For example, this model
How smart would you say it is?
I think
Doubao is definitely not as smart as Gemini or Claude
But first of all, Doubao
For example, Doubao's voice generation is extremely good
Wait, is that difficult?
Technically, Doubao is indeed the best at it
Because I find that for life questions
I just want to ask Doubao
Because it's so fast
But other models
Why don't they optimize this product feature?
I think it still has to do with their user base
In the US
I think people are more focused on
how to improve work efficiency
Don't you have life questions?
I do in my life
First of all
I personally
am indeed pretty boring in my personal life
So I don't have many interesting life dilemmas
to ask Doubao
The questions I have more often in life
are all technical ones
Asking a smart model like Gemini is the best
Hahahaha
Right
I don't have this urge to open Doubao at midnight
for late-night emotional support
It's not just emotions, but many things
Like when you're cooking
Hmm
You might run into some problem
You might need someone to tell you right away
But you don't have such a person
Hmm, those
I think it's probably more of a data issue
And probably for US companies
the main priority right now is intelligence
or work efficiency
Someday in the future
Will it become these daily matters?
I think it's possible
The fact is
If you ask about these daily topics
actually
you'll find that Gemini
from generation to generation
does better and better
Hmm
Actually, many of my friends
including myself in the past
When I was at Anthropic before
I might ask Claude to write code
But for daily lookups
I would ask Gemini, right
Have you used Doubao?
I've actually only used it once or twice
I noticed you guys don't really use it much
Hmm, first of all
Is it a pecking order thing?
(There's an intelligence pecking order) Hahaha, no no, not that serious
I just think first of all
It's like people in China trying to use American models
There are some complicated things involved
Oh
Me using Chinese models in the US
is actually quite complicated too
Second, I simply don't have the motivation for it
Especially since I think in my life
Work is work
When I'm relaxing, I just find different work to do
So for me
My best companions are Claude and Gemini
But it might not be like that for others
So it might just be my personal thing
The one or two times I used Doubao myself
It was because someone showed me the Doubao phone
Hahahaha, right
So what do you think of the Doubao phone?
I think it's a great idea
Personally, in terms of results
They actually did a pretty good job
Of course, what I don't know is
Technically, how well optimized it is
I mean, it
I think it executes some tasks in real time
From a results perspective, there's no problem
But I don't know how much overhead it has
If that overhead is very, very large
Then it's probably a technical issue that needs to be solved. Mm-hmm.
Because you don't want, you know
Your model to book a high-speed train ticket for you
And end up costing more than the ticket itself
That would definitely be unacceptable
Right, so
Technically speaking
I personally don't know how mature it is
And from a product perspective
For everyone, it's still quite
Can't say surprising
But it's something that gets people pretty excited
And I think
Apple probably wanted to do something like this before
It's just that Apple's own models haven't been that great
Apple doesn't seem to care much about its AI strategy
Now, I think
Apple definitely cares about AI strategy
Because Siri, the phone assistant
Was in Apple's product launches
A very, very important highlight
But their own models didn't catch up
Now they might be trying to do this through a partnership with Gemini
To try to make it happen
As for whether they care about it now
First of all, I don't know
If you ask me to guess, I'd definitely say they care
But if you ask me to explain
Why from the outside it doesn't look like they care that much
My only guess is that
If from the outside it looks like you care a lot
And you still can't pull it off
Then you just look stupid
Ah
Saving face
Ah, right, hahaha (I don't care)
Then let's talk about Doubao's model
You just said Doubao's model is quite distinctive
Can you be more specific?
One is that its voice is really well done
That's the first point
I think the voice is really well done
It's the most distinctive thing I can feel
I mean, I think the voice quality might be
To put it politely, probably one of the best in the world
To put it bluntly
I think it's simply the best in the world
Mm. Is that hard?
Mm
I haven't gotten to that level myself
So I don't know if it's hard or not
But I think it might be something that takes a lot of effort
Whether in terms of data or various optimizations
Is it a product thing or a model thing?
It has to be a model thing
It might also include some product aspects
But it's definitely a model thing
Right. And then
I think that's one aspect
And on the other hand
On the other hand, I don't have that much personal experience
Because I haven't actually used it that much
So it's probably more from
Feedback from friends and family
That is
Hey, this Doubao model is just fun to talk
It's just fun to chat with
Haha, right
But I think that
Is more of some subjective feedback
I think one is the voice
And another is that it
Generates very fast, which is also very important
Because many models
Are showing you their chain of thought
But I'm talking about trivial things in your daily life
I don't want to see its chain of thought
Right. I don't think this is technically difficult
It's just that maybe
People haven't spent more time on it yet
On this
And the fact is
If you try Gemini 2.5 Pro and Gemini 2.5 Flash
You'll find
Gemini 2.5 Flash
When completing the same problem
It's already much faster than before
And much less fluff
So I don't think this is a
Mm-hmm, in my view it's not a technical difficulty
It's more about when to pay attention to it
And do something about it
I think maybe it's now
Right now these American companies
Are all still in the stage of
Working hard to push the upper limits of intelligence forward
And ByteDance
Of course it's also pushing the upper limits
But I think
It might just be doing very well in user optimization too
Also doing quite well
Recently there's another topic
That Chinese robots are very hot right now
At the Spring Festival Gala
I don't know if you have any observations about this
I've watched some performances
Also searched for some prices on Amazon
I was really surprised they're so cheap
Haha, did you buy one
No, haha
I wouldn't have any use for it even if I bought one
But indeed I used to
I don't know, in my mind I thought humanoid robots
And
Of course at the software level there's nothing really
But mainly hardware
I thought for hardware to be this mature
It would probably cost something like
Several million dollars or something
But it seems when I checked
The price is much cheaper than that
I think this still reflects
China's hardware industry chain
Still has a lot of advantages
But I
Don't really know if it
As a
As a robot
In terms of hardware
I think it's indeed very very strong
And from the software perspective
I haven't quite figured it out
I think robot models
Are also something with relatively large disagreement right now
Right
What do you mean
What I mean is
I think robot models are probably more in the
Feature engineering era
Like you have a given environment
A given scenario
You optimize for that scenario
People know how to do that
Mm-hmm but doing RL
Doing reinforcement learning
Building appropriate virtual environments
Still virtual
This kind of
This kind of data
Then you do training
Can improve
But it doesn't have strong generalization
I think this is
Whether there is generalization
Is actually a watershed for many AI directions
A deterministic scenario
A very single scenario
Can you do this well
This wasn't solved just in recent years
It could be done more than ten years ago
Like language is also language
In this era before Transformer-like architectures
It wasn't completely impossible
Right, back then
You could also train very strong models to do translation
Mm-hmm
You could train a very strong model
To do semantic analysis
But what you couldn't do is
I can improve all abilities across the board
By improving at one level
Mm-hmm
I think this is a watershed
And I think language models
After Transformer and GPT
Entered that kind of stage
Crossed a threshold
Where you can improve all abilities by improving at one level
And you might train at one point
It will abstract this ability
And generalize it to all related things
But I think robots haven't reached that stage
More still before that stage
Where I have a single scenario
A single thing
Then I can optimize for that
So what do you think
About these robotics teams in Silicon Valley
And there are also a lot of robotics people inside Gemini
Mm
What do you think
That direction is a bit...
What would you call it
Is it a sub-direction of yours
Or a parallel direction
Or what
I think
In the past, it was quite a parallel direction
But now, for robotics
I think people are also trying
To see if they can leverage language models
As a base model
And then train something like
For example, VLA (Vision-Language-Action model)
Especially multimodal models
Right, right, right, and um
So now
It has become something closely related
To the language model track
Mm
And personally, my feeling is
They will become very important in the future
But they haven't found their own path yet
But what they're doing is really interesting
I highly recommend everyone go check out
Robotics labs
They're way more interesting than language model labs
Language model labs
Feel like normal offices
But robotics labs, they really
Have people controlling these robots
Collecting all kinds of data
And watching the robot in like
Shelves picking up all sorts of items and stuff
Doing things like that
I think it's a very interesting thing
Which one did you go to
Ah, I went to
Wait, Gemini's own lab
No, not Gemini
Google DeepMind's own lab
I've been to see it
And also that Dyna
I've also been to see
They have a clothes-folding robot
Right, their scenario might be a bit more narrow
Like folding clothes
Is one robot, maybe doing some other things
Like pouring water and stuff
Right, like that
Your intuitive feeling
Where does robotics progress compare to in LLM years
It hasn't reached the GPT-1 moment yet, right
Definitely not
I think it definitely hasn't, right
Mm
It's like everyone still hasn't
Figured out how to scale up
I think for me
Whether it's robotics or multimodal generation
Neither has reached that point
Then let's get into today's main topic
We're still very interested in you
And chat about
How you went from someone who studied physics
Into the world of AI
Mm
Where did you grow up
How did you grow up
I
I was born in Ningxia
In a very, very small city
Called Dawukou
See, that confused expression of yours
Already shows how small this city is
Mm
This city existed in the past because of a coal mine
Also because of Shitanjing
A coal mine
And then this city came into being
Right, so I was born there
But I
Went to Shanghai with my parents during elementary school
And so
The latter half of elementary school and my middle and high school were in Shanghai
Then I went to Beijing for undergrad
What I just mentioned
Undergrad in Beijing
Then PhD in the US
Right
You had good grades since you were young, right
You got into university through physics competition
And studied theoretical physics at Tsinghua and Stanford
Right, I didn't get in through physics competition
Hahaha
I think I was quite mediocre when I was young
Hahahaha
Ah first of all
The middle school and elementary school I attended were both nobodies
Hahaha
I think I
The middle school I attended at that time, competitions
Were not something you should consider
It was that kind of middle school
Called Shangnan Middle School East Campus
Another school that makes everyone confused
A school that leaves people baffled
Okay, since we're here, which elementary school was it
What was the elementary school called (Dezhou Second Village Elementary School)
My context management ability is too strong
I can't even remember what it's called actually
Hahaha, mm-hmm, right
And right
It was that middle school
It was um
In a small environment within one class
There were still some classmates who wanted to do things properly
But overall
I think that middle school was in a relatively laid-back state
Right, and
I think maybe my grades were okay (What do you mean by okay)
Okay means at that time the situation was
Shanghai high schools had so-called
At that time there were so-called four top schools
Like Shanghai High School
Then Hua Er
Jiao Tong and Fudan affiliated high schools
Right
And at that time the situation was I could get into these four schools
But couldn't get into the best classes in these four schools
But at that time I really wanted to do competitions
Because I had never done competitions before
You started competitions in middle school
I didn't do competitions in middle school
Oh, I never did competitions in middle school
Why did you want to do competitions if you never did them
Because I never did them
So I wanted to do them
How did you get that idea (Hahaha, that's just how I am)
My personality is
I always love doing things I'm not good at
Hahahaha, right
And at that time I hadn't done competitions
But I knew about them
So I felt that compulsory education
Not compulsory education, but before going to college I should give it a try
So but then
My grades weren't good enough for that
So
Going to the four top schools, the best four schools
I couldn't get into their competition classes
Then I discovered there was a slightly worse school
That school was Gezhi High School
A slightly worse school
But that school had a competition class
And I felt this competition class
In today's terms it's an underdog
Hahahaha
Impressive
In the words of that time, I felt like the barefoot aren't afraid of those wearing shoes
Hahahaha
I think, mm-hmm
Worth a shot
So actually at that time, back then
At that time
Shanghai still had this so-called early admission system
Where before the high school entrance exam
You could sign a contract with a school
And then you would reserve a spot at that school in advance
And then go directly there
And then it was very natural to go
And then go do competition high school
So you were actually between the regular classes of Shanghai's four top schools
And the competition class of Gezhi High School
Without hesitation
Chose Gezhi High School's competition class
Of course I can't say
I can't say that when I made the choice
Getting into the best four high schools
Was a sure thing
Although my score was indeed enough later
At that time the high school entrance exam hadn't happened yet
Right right but at that time I felt
Even if I could get in
I should go to an underdog place and take a gamble
Why
Because I wanted to do this
What was your purpose for wanting to do competitions
I think the main thing at that time was wanting to experience it
I felt I hadn't done it
I had to find an opportunity to do it
Why did you have to do it
First, I felt it was indeed difficult
Ah, it was indeed more
There was just this excitement about difficulty
Right
It's indeed
At least at that time
Before I started
The impression everyone gave me was
That this thing was much more challenging
Than the stuff you learn without doing competitions
Mm-hmm
The people who do this seem really strong
If you don't do it you're just the smoothest stone
Among all the mediocre rocks
So at that time I felt I should do it
So I went and did it
Of course doing it actually brought some benefits
Looking back later
If I hadn't done competitions at that time
I probably wouldn't have gotten into Tsinghua
Oh, did you get bonus points or something
At that time actually
The competition direct admission system had already declined significantly
Only those who made the national training team could get direct admission
My high school
Anyway I think
I wasn't at the level of making the national training team
So let's not talk about that
But before taking the senior year competition exam
By a twist of fate I went to Tsinghua for a summer camp
And by a twist of fate on the last day of the summer camp
I heard they were doing
Independent enrollment
But mainly aimed at Beijing students
I frantically texted the admissions office teacher
Saying I wanted to take the exam with them
He agreed
And then he agreed to let us take the exam
You all or just you
Just agreed
Me
And the few people from our high school who went together
Those high school classmates from Shanghai who went to that summer camp
Oh what reason did you use to convince him to text him
I've forgotten the specifics of that text
But the general idea of that text was
You give Beijing students the exam
Why not give Shanghai students the exam
Oh, you were quite righteous about it
Did you think they were playing favorites at that time
I didn't think they were playing favorites
I just felt they had this opportunity
Why not give it to us
Everyone's competing on the same playing field
You were classmates at that time
And so I sent this message
And they actually let us take the exam
How many people
I can't quite remember
Maybe from Shanghai
There were probably about seven or eight people in that exam room
You sent that text
Maybe
Maybe other high schools had other students who sent texts too
But from our high school I was the one who sent it
Oh so
They were all Shanghai high schools
Students who went to Beijing for that summer camp
Students who attended the summer camp
And then they let us take the exam
And then we signed
That easy to talk to
Right, so what I learned from that incident
The most important life lesson is
Be bold
Haha
If you don't fight for it you'll never get it
Even if you fight for it you might not get it
But if you don't fight for it you definitely won't get it
Were you nervous when you sent that text
You were still in high school
I can't remember anymore
At that time I felt
Was this a very bold thing for me
No, at that time I was completely thinking
I have to fight for it now
If I don't fight for it today I won't be able to fight for it tomorrow haha
Like
The day I heard about it I immediately started frantically texting
Frantically texting who
Texting the admissions office
That Tsinghua admissions office teacher
Texting one person or multiple people
Can't remember, probably one teacher
Did he reply quickly
Mm-hmm mm-hmm I think Tsinghua
Just said yes
I don't know if they discussed it among themselves
But anyway in the end they said they agreed
And then we took the exam together
Right
So I so I
Why do I feel like
I've always had quite a soft spot for Tsinghua
I just feel
that this school is willing to give people opportunities
to provide equal opportunities for everyone
How did you do on that exam?
Well, when I came out, I felt like I totally bombed it
Because I couldn't solve half a problem
But later I found out others missed even more
So I did get in after all
Hahaha, yeah, exactly
How many of your Shanghai classmates got in that year?
Ah, I think two
Independent recruitment
Was it a score reduction or something?
It lowered the cutoff to the first-tier university line
Lowered to the first-tier line
Oh
So how did you do on the gaokao?
Later, sure enough, my gaokao wasn't high enough for Tsinghua
But I could get into any school except Tsinghua and Peking University
Oh
So why
Online it says you were recommended for admission
I think it's just that people
who didn't go to school during those years find it hard
hard to really understand what happened back then
Because two cohorts before mine
you could still get recommended admission with a provincial first prize
A provincial first prize got you recommended admission
What about your time?
In our time, with a provincial first prize
you made the provincial team
then represented the provincial team at the national competition
and only by making the national training team could you get recommended admission
I made the provincial team and went to the national competition
But I didn't make the national training team
Right
So in my year, I didn't have a recommended admission slot
Oh
Were you good at competitions?
I think I was pretty mediocre
Like
Isn't not being the best basically the same as being mediocre?
And I obviously wasn't the best
So I was just mediocre
What was your family's attitude toward you doing competitions?
What was their attitude?
The best thing about my parents is
they didn't really interfere much
They may have tried to control me at some point
but later found they couldn't
Oh, how so?
I just didn't listen to them
Oh
I think most Chinese families
it's already considered pretty good when kids discuss things with their parents
I usually just informed them
Haha, informed them of what?
Informed them, oh, I'm going to the independent recruitment exam
Yeah, and
Including filling out applications for high school and college
My parents might not have even seen my application forms
Oh, they're pretty laid-back, huh?
I think they just
when you can't understand what someone is doing
the best thing is to not meddle
I think my parents understood this very well
Yeah, hahaha
So you're pretty rebellious, huh?
I think I am
Pretty
My personality is
I really care about what I want to do
If it's something I've figured out I want to do
Don't try to stop me
And I'll definitely do my absolute best
But if it's something I don't want to do
Forcing me won't help, I won't do it. Right
Are you very competitive?
Pretty strong
Yeah, but I think I'm more competing with myself
pushing myself, I guess
Not really willing to compete with others
Oh, right
Of course, if
well
it's something I think is important
and you also think it's important
then I definitely have to outdo you, hehe
So then you got to Tsinghua, that was even more amazing
You studied quantum physics, why?
Yeah, I was doing condensed matter theory at the time
Why did you choose this major?
A twist of fate
Looking back now
Of course I can
come up with some very reasonable-sounding explanations
But honestly, going back to that time
I think it was just a twist of fate
So at that time we were in the Jixian class
And the Jixian class had a very good tradition
First of all, although the Jixian class was in the physics department
It didn't restrict what students could do
Actually 2/3 of the students in the Jixian class wouldn't do physics
Ah
And for
Why did you enter this class
Uh
At that time the entire Tsinghua physics department was Jixian class
Maybe not anymore now
Anyway it was at that time
And another good tradition it had was
It encouraged students to learn through practice
So it encouraged students
To enter research labs as early as possible
And learn through research
And at that time I really wanted to do theory
Was it because you found it difficult
It feels like you have a fascination with difficulty
Maybe it's also a kind of illness
I can talk more about this later
What are the bad consequences of this illness
Hahaha
Right and then then right
Then I wanted to do theory
And of course the Jixian class
Or what we call the Xuetang class
Had a smaller class
And then the
Teacher recommended saying hey
The Institute for Advanced Study is a great place
Tsinghua Institute for Advanced Study
The research institute founded by Mr. Chen-Ning Yang
Is a great place
So I went there to find a teacher
And there happened to be
A teacher who was still young at that time called
Called Wang Zhong, he was my undergraduate teacher
Mm-hmm, at that time he didn't have many students either
And we chatted
Of course I knew nothing
But he was quite patient
And gave me
Gave me some papers to read
And after reading I discussed with him
Later I discovered condensed matter theory
Especially the project we were doing at that time
Was related to topological insulators
And these kinds of directions
Actually
Was a direction very suitable for undergraduates to get started with
It didn't require too much background knowledge
You only needed to know
The most basic thing is you need to know quantum mechanics
Statistical mechanics
Solid state physics
Which are actually very very easy to learn
Basic knowledge
But it might really test
The depth of your understanding of this knowledge
So for undergraduates
It's actually a particularly good direction
Where you can get started quickly
And do some actual projects
And then we did some work together
Among which possibly
The work in open quantum systems
Looking back now is still quite important work
Right and then
In a sense
I think looking back now
Doing that work
Doing research during that period
Is actually very very similar to doing AI now
It's more that you have an idea
You have an understanding
And at that stage you can
You can do a numerical experiment
To verify whether your idea and understanding are correct
You find AI is actually the same
AI is also you have an idea
You have an understanding
You design some experiments
To verify whether your understanding is correct
And then you design some model
Training pipeline
To implement your ideas
Right so actually these two are very similar
Can you talk about your non-Hermitian system research
Ah, I can talk about it
I'll try to speak in human terms
But it's also possible I'll actually be talking nonsense
So those who don't want to listen can skip ahead
Hahahaha
Slide the progress bar
You can set two markers on the progress bar
Right and then right
Non-Hermitian systems are like this
One of the most basic assumptions of quantum mechanics is
An isolated system
Its evolution is described by unitary evolution
Unitary evolution is kind of nonsense
Sorry
What unitary evolution means is
It's a linear process
And this linear process
Can be described by an operator
Called the Hamiltonian
Ah, the Hamiltonian, in a certain sense
It's somewhat like the energy of the system
But not exactly
It's somewhat analogous to
So
It determines how the system evolves over time
And if it's
An isolated system
This Hamiltonian will be a Hermitian matrix
A Hermitian matrix is one where you transpose it
And then take the complex conjugate
And it's the same as the original
But real systems
The vast majority are not isolated systems
For example, you
Me, as a human being
Definitely have to exchange information with the outside world
And exchange matter
Materials are the same
If you put a piece of material there
Unless you create an extremely high vacuum
You always have to interact with the substrate
You have to exchange with the external environment
So real systems
Are mostly not isolated systems
And isolated systems
Won't be described by a unitary process
And the corresponding Hamiltonian
Won't be Hermitian either
Hamiltonian
That's where the term 'non-Hermitian' comes from
It's essentially for studying open quantum systems
Quantum systems that exchange with the outside world
Their behavior
And at that time, something very puzzling was discovered
We were initially trying to study
Some topological phenomena in these open quantum systems
And then we found
The theoretical results from hand calculations
Just couldn't match the numerical results no matter what
More precisely
The hand calculation result
Assumed the system
Had periodic boundary conditions
For example, on a ring
Or on the surface of a torus
And numerically
Because it's closer to the actual situation
It would calculate with open boundaries
For example, the behavior of a material in a square shape
And these two results just couldn't be reconciled
So we tried to understand this
And later found
The basic paradigm people used to describe Hermitian systems
A fundamental paradigm
Is the so-called Bloch wave
Which assumes the eigenstates of the system are
Linear combinations of waves
This
Sine and cosine waves, that kind of thing
Linear combinations of such waves
This assumption
In non-Hermitian systems, it actually
breaks down — it becomes wrong
The fact is
Later we found
In non-Hermitian systems
Actually, the energy eigenstates
All
Can potentially accumulate at one edge of the system
Right, and then we systematically established this
Set of descriptive methods
And then built a framework
To describe a non-Hermitian system with open boundaries
How to describe its eigenstates
And thereby describe its time evolution
And some dynamics
So
That was the work at that time
And later there was a lot of
Because it was actually a
A paradigm shift
So later there was a lot of
Follow-up work
But later I actually switched directions
So I didn't continue much in this direction
Why didn't you continue with it
It's hard to catch a paradigm shift, isn't it
It's hard to catch a paradigm shift
Yes, yes
This is the weakness of human nature
I feel like
I always love challenging myself with things I don't know
Hahaha especially at that time
Just
I don't know what I was feeling in that direction
Maybe looking back at that work a few years later
It would become the most important work in that direction
Later when you do some more work
It might indeed make you more famous
Get more citations
Write more good journal articles
Find a good faculty position
But it feels like for a scientific career
It wouldn't be that exciting
So at that time I wanted to switch to something else
Switch to something I wasn't good at
Do it right
And then
So when doing my PhD I switched directions
To do high energy theory
High energy theory, right
High energy physics, right
So your undergraduate and PhD were also different
Also different
It's not just jumping from physics to AI
Actually your undergraduate and PhD both look like physics
But the directions had already changed significantly
Right, two directions with almost no connection
Oh, that's quite amazing
Including your choice of competitions
Going to Gezhi High School was also quite amazing
Right
What kind of human nature is this
I think it's just
To put it badly, I love torturing myself
Hahaha, to put it nicely, challenging myself
Hahaha
Mm-hmm, are you happy being tortured
I think if someone tortures themselves just for the sake of being tortured
Then that person has psychological issues
But
If a person is being tortured in order to learn more things
And enrich their experiences and abilities
I think it's worth it
Your undergraduate teacher
Teacher Wang Zhong was also an underdog, right
Does he count
No, hahaha
He was doing quite well
How can you say that about him haha (At that time)
I just said he was very young
No no no, he was very young
But he
My impression of him has always been
He is a very sharp person
Very capable of seeing problems
Trying to understand problems
Understanding them very clearly
Indeed he might not be like many teachers who are
Very famous
In society or very dazzling
At least not at that time
Now he's very famous
At that time he wasn't that famous yet
But I think in terms of ability
I think he's very strong
Right, and actually he started out
When he was doing his PhD he studied with Teacher Shoucheng
Teacher Zhang Shoucheng
So
People who can be chosen by Teacher Shoucheng
Basically won't be too bad
Mm-hmm
Did he say anything about you changing directions for your PhD
He didn't say anything
I think he is
He is someone who doesn't like to interfere with others
Hahahaha
I don't know what he was thinking inside
But I think
He is someone who doesn't like to interfere with others
Eh, quantum physics
What kind of worldview is it as a whole
It and, um
I think
I think the biggest difference is I think, um
There are many
Many differences from classical physics
But I think
They are two corresponding concepts, right
Classical physics and quantum physics
They are theories at different energy and time
Or spatial scales
That is, essentially our world is all quantum
Of course right now
We don't know what exists at smaller scales
Right, like
At smaller scales
There are many different ideas
For example, string theory is an idea
And then look at other ideas
Quantum gravity is also an idea, things like that
Right, but none of those can be verified
Verified
The effective theory at the smallest scales is quantum physics
The tiniest, tiniest scales
That can be experimentally verified
The effective theory at the smallest scales is quantum
Of course, this includes quantum mechanics and quantum field theory
And classical physics is
When the spatial scale you're looking at and
Is relatively large
This quantum physics
Will gradually, gradually reduce to classical physics
Actually, it's more about at different scales
Having different effective theories
This, this thing
Is actually a very profound idea in physics
It's what's called the renormalization group
What the renormalization group says
Is that
The theory describing a system
At different energy scales
May look completely different
Right, and even if they may ultimately, at the root
Are all a grand unified theory
Of course, right now
There isn't really a true grand unified theory
If one exists
Even if they share the same root at the origin
But at different scales
They may also look completely different
So classical physics and
Quantum physics
Are more like two descriptions at different scales
Speaking of quantum physics
There are several terms that seem related
For example, the butterfly effect
For example, quantum entanglement
Can you talk about these
I think this is something everyone can understand
And I don't know physics either
Don't blame me, everyone
I don't know quantum physics either
Right, I think
Quantum entanglement
Is indeed something relatively well-known
And quite unique to quantum physics
And then it's very simple
It's like, say I have two particles
For example, they're in an entangled state
And then maybe they're actually very far apart
But actually
If I perform some measurement on one of them
Or perturbation
It will also affect the state of the other
This is real
This is real, right
What kinds of things have quantum entanglement
What kinds of two objects, there are many
There are many
Just, there are many
Actual situations
It's actually
When you look closely enough, enough, enough
At a small enough, microscopic scale
The vast majority of particles may be in entangled states
But practically speaking
You can
For example, create one spin and another spin
First bring them together
Then collapse them into an entangled state
Then you can pull one of them very far away
Then it becomes an entanglement
A state entangled over a long distance
And I think even, I remember a few years ago
There were people who specifically did experiments
Putting a bacterium and some other thing
Into a quantum entangled state
What do you mean by prepare
This can be manually operated
This is something that can be manually operated
Why, how do you operate it
Generally speaking
It's through some
Some measurements and the action of evolution operators
Can put it
Into this state
But the hard part here
Is actually how to implement this experimentally
This process
You can imagine
It's like you perform some quantum measurements
And some, some so-called quantum gate operations
Actually
It's quite difficult
Which brings us back to the question just now
That every system is actually not isolated
You might have these two spins
And you think, hey
If I prepare them this way
Don't I get an entangled state?
Then I just separate them and I'm done
But the real problem is
These two particles actually live in our world
Other particles constantly
Bump into them
Or external heat disturbs them a bit
And the state is gone just like that
So the hard part is
How to actually implement this process experimentally
Right, and then
Another example of entanglement might be more well-known
I should actually mention that example
Which is Schrödinger's cat
Schrödinger's cat
That's a much more famous example
It says its state is actually a superposition
Of a radioactive source emitting a particle
And the cat being dead
That's one state
The other state is the radioactive source not emitting a particle
And the cat being alive, a superposition of these two
So for example
If you measure that radioactive source
And find that it emitted a particle
You know the cat is dead
No matter how far apart the cat and the source are
Right, so that's entanglement
But the butterfly effect is a
Is a different thing
And the butterfly effect
Well the famous part of the butterfly effect
Is actually from classical physics
What people hear about in classical physics
The butterfly effect is that famous example
Where maybe a butterfly in South America
Flaps its wings
Half a month later
A typhoon hits North America
But from a more mathematical formulation
It says that at time
At the initial moment
If you make a very tiny perturbation
And then measure the impact of this perturbation
How large it becomes in the future
You'll find
That this perturbation grows exponentially
Right, that's mathematically
A description of the classical butterfly effect
But something people were puzzled about before
Is how could this phenomenon exist in quantum systems
Because as we just said, isolated
An isolated quantum system undergoes unitary evolution
It's a very linear process
So in a certain sense
If you have one state
That is, one vector and another vector
With not too large an angle between them initially
Then after some evolution
This angle shouldn't change
And so there should always exist
This situation where initial states are
Very slightly different
And in the future, bam, it grows exponentially
That seems from quantum mechanics, like
Something unlikely to happen
But as we just said
Our world is actually quantum at the microscopic level
And becomes classical at the macroscopic level
But they're part of the same continuum
How can one have it and not the other
That's what people were trying to understand
And of course
Later people gained a better understanding
Which is that actually
When discussing the butterfly effect in quantum systems
You shouldn't discuss the change between two states
This change
Instead you should discuss something
Called local observable（局域可观测量）
That is, the change in local observables
That actually corresponds to what you see
In classical physics, those changes
So after four years of studying quantum physics
What were you thinking at the time
What do you think physics helped you with
When you were about to graduate as a senior
I think the biggest benefit of studying physics as an undergraduate
Is first of all
Think things through clearly
Reading isn't about reading a lot
But about reading deeply
Reading a lot doesn't mean you can discover new things
But if you have
A perspective different from others on something
That's what's more valuable
To society
This one thing
And another thing is don't trust theory too much
Don't trust pure theory too much
Because
I came to this conclusion
Because the main reason that discovery happened at that time
Was because we could do numerics
It started because numerics and theory didn't match
Then we carefully studied that problem
And discovered this thing
Then why did you go study high energy physics for your PhD
That's also a theory
This brings us back to the topic we just discussed
That always loving to challenge very difficult things
Sometimes also brings some bad results
What bad results
For example I feel like
I think my PhD, for myself personally
I learned a lot
Grew a lot
But for this world
It didn't produce any contribution
Haha, this high energy theory direction
It's difficult enough
Very very difficult
And um
But the bad thing about it is
It's actually not particularly verifiable
There are no objective evaluation criteria
Because
High energy theory has developed to the point where
Experiments completely can't catch up at this stage
Experiments completely can't catch up to what you're discussing in theory
Whether it's energy scales
Or these microscopic scales
Right
How does it progress
What does its progress depend on
If not experiments
One source of progress
Comes from mathematical self-consistency
Mm-hmm, like for example
You propose a framework
To describe these things
Then can you be self-consistent with existing
Already verified theories at lower energy scales
Like for example
You study string theory
Then naturally the question everyone asks is
Can string theory at low energy
Return to quantum field theory
And then return to classical physics
Then this self-consistency is one criterion
I think this is very reasonable
A very scientific thing
Of course there are also some unscientific factors
That when this field completely lacks experiments
And objective standards
There definitely won't be just one framework that appears
There definitely won't be just one self-consistent framework that appears
At this time who does well
Who doesn't do well
Actually depends on
The subjective judgments of some old-timers in the field
Did someone hurt you
I wasn't hurt by anyone
It's just that the longer I stayed in that field
The more I felt this thing was stupid, like
A person's life isn't that long
Why waste your own time
Serving old-timers
Right
So it feels like spending 5 years learning a lot of knowledge
Buying a big lesson
This lesson is
This big lesson is to (do experiments)
Hey, it's about doing
Things with relatively objective evaluation criteria
Mm-hmm, or from another perspective
Or from another perspective
Like
Do things that can have an impact on this world
So actually your undergraduate went relatively smoothly, right
In the quantum physics research field
Very quickly
You very quickly had very good academic results
And it was paradigm-level change
But you quickly felt it wasn't attractive anymore
So
You wanted to challenge something more difficult in your PhD
Right
And during the PhD period it was actually quite lonely
At least in terms of results it was like that
Hahaha
The outside world couldn't tell
From the outside it all looks like a very glamorous resume
PhD at Stanford
Right, I think
In terms of actual research output
I think
No one would say my PhD papers were bad
But if I'm being completely honest
How much impact did they have on the world?
I think almost none
No impact, practically zero
Right, so for me personally
I was really unhappy with that
But I also wasn't unhappy enough to, you know
worry that people would say I was slacking off
I really wasn't slacking off
You can still meet all the external expectations
Right
How do you pull that off?
Well, this is something that
You know how it really feels, right?
Right, exactly
I think meeting external expectations
Or meeting the standards of a small circle
It's like training a model
Once you're in that small circle
And you know what their evaluation criteria are
It's easy to do well
Even if you don't actually believe in those standards
You can still meet them
Mhm
But deep down, you know you don't buy into them
Because sometimes even when you don't believe in it
And you hit those marks
You can fool yourself and just keep moving forward
But I eventually realized I couldn't fool myself
Couldn't lie to myself
Mhm
Right
When did you realize that?
I think probably around
The last two years of my PhD
I started having that feeling
But back then, I hadn't really figured it out yet
Hadn't figured out what to do if not this
So I spent some time
Exploring different directions
For example
At first I mostly looked into
Quantum computing
Or quantum information, that kind of direction
Then I got a postdoc offer
After getting the postdoc offer
It felt more urgent
Because when you're still in school
You can still have a student mindset
After leaving school, it's your own career（事业）
You have to carve out a path for yourself
So at the time I felt
Quantum computing and AI were probably two
I think they offer young people
More opportunities
So what was your postdoc direction?
The postdoc had no direction
It was basically just theoretical physics
A postdoc is a very independent position
You basically do whatever you want
Right, it's more like
In a way, it's kind of like doing charity
Huh?
Who's doing charity?
Well, there are probably some
Whether it's government organizations that care about research
Or private organizations
They donate money
To the university
Or allocate funding to the school
The school uses that money to hire postdocs
Who then do research in a department
And share their research
Broadly with other people in the department
I think it's more about creating a kind of social atmosphere
This kind of
This kind of work
Right, and so
So there really aren't many restrictions
You can basically do whatever you want
But I didn't actually do
The postdoc for very long
I was probably at Berkeley for two or three months in reality
But officially, I was only there for two weeks
What do you mean by officially?
I mean
I had actually already gone there before I officially started
Because I was already in the Bay Area anyway
I went there before I officially started
But after I officially started
I only stayed for two weeks before quitting
What happened during those two weeks?
Nothing happened in those two weeks
I wasn't even planning to start the position
But the people at Berkeley were just too nice
They were like, uh
No worries, just wait until things are settled
Come for as long as you can
Oh, so you told them you were actually talking to Anthropic
Right
I told them
Actually I think I might go do AI
Maybe I shouldn't join
Mm-hmm
But Berkeley wasn't
Not just Berkeley
I think the Bay Area
Teachers at both these schools are very nice
They really take care of you
They felt you haven't fully finalized things yet
So better hold onto the current job first
Do you think physics helped you later when doing AI
In what ways
I think in terms of hard skills there wasn't much help
In terms of pure tool-based skills
Actually the transfer from physics to AI
Is very very little
But I think if you really have to ask
I think maybe the main
Main
No
Can't say it's ability
It's personality
Maybe
Maybe physics people want to get to the bottom of things more
Want to understand something more
And want to do things more systematically
Because we're used to this very systematic
Whether it's experimental methods
Or theoretical methods
So I think this might be
A good thing
But
I don't think this is unique to physics people either
Like
Why wouldn't computer science people have this trait
I know many computer science people
Who also have this trait
Many chemistry people also have this trait
Biology students also have this trait
So I don't think it's unique to physics
Right but actually it's quite interesting
There are indeed many in this field
Especially with language models
This kind of large scale AI
There are indeed many people from physics backgrounds
Who have been very successful
Right especially at Anthropic this company
When many people describe this generation of AI
They all say it's a black box
Can you use a scientific perspective
To understand this black box
The operating principles of artificial intelligence
I think
Everything in this world is a black box
Like even physics
Something everyone thinks they understand
Actually doesn't really have
An understanding from its microscopic behavior
All the way to macroscopic manifestations
Like whether it's quantum mechanics
Or quantum field theory
They all describe behavior at that energy scale
Essentially the system is still a black box
You still don't know at its most microscopic level
What kind of dynamics
AI is the same
Whether it's a black box or not
Is actually all relative
We indeed don't understand language models to the level of
Neurosurgery-level precision
It's not that I understand this behavior
To the extent of
Saying this behavior is caused by which neuron
Which artificial neuron's which activation
Producing this behavior
We don't have that
Haven't reached that level of understanding
Except in some very sparse
Very small networks
Like Anthropic
Has this so-called Interpretability
Interpretability team
They might do some similar work
But in practically usable language models
We haven't reached such understanding
But it doesn't mean we have no understanding at all
For example Scaling Law
It describes how models at that scale
With model size and data improve in perplexity
Under this metric get better and better
Mm-hmm so you say there's no understanding at all
Well if
Scaling Law
Doesn't count as a small part of understanding
Then can we also say
We actually don't understand this world at all either
This world is also a complete black box
So Scaling Law is a scientific law
It's an empirical law
An empirical law
Right
But
The boundary between empirical laws and scientific laws
is quite blurry
For example
If we look back at these thermodynamic
various different laws
The first law, the second law
The Clapeyron equation and whatnot
all this messy stuff
When they were first discovered
they were also empirical laws
It's just that later on
as time went by
we gradually understood their microscopic mechanisms
Then they might have become scientific laws
Right, I think maybe something like Scaling Law
or things like that
Right now it's definitely still very impressive
But in the future, when the technology becomes more fixed
and people start to understand it more and more
the microscopic process
will it become a scientific law
if such a definition exists
I think it's possible
Can you explain in scientific terms
this so-called intelligence emergence
First of all, this term itself isn't very scientific
So naturally there's no way to use scientific language
to describe something unscientific
Intelligence emergence?
Well, I think intelligence emergence
to me it's more of a subjective feeling
rather than an objective phenomenon
When many people talk about intelligence emergence
what they might have in mind is that previous language
models could only do one type of thing
like only translation
only analysis
only certain things
But now it seems like the model
can do everything
But this thing
Again, I think it's like
to me
it's more of a technical emergence
rather than a behavioral emergence
It's that through research
we discovered
how to do this kind of large-scale training
and then be able to lift all capabilities across the board
I think this is the more fundamental thing
As for intelligence emergence itself
Actually, I think, um
everyone probably has a different definition in mind
Right
Your definition is
To me, there's no definition
Haha, to me
The only qualitative difference is
whether there's been a technical breakthrough
that allows us to scale up
and lift all capabilities across the board
This, to me
is a well-defined thing
You ended up choosing AI
between quantum computing and AI
How did this shift happen
Right, I think I still spent
some time understanding
where the bottlenecks lie in both directions
I think the good thing is they both give young people opportunities
The good thing is
both have opportunities
But quantum computing seemed to you
to be closer to your main path
at that time, right
Well, that's why I needed to understand the details
Because after understanding the details, I found out it's not
It's the opposite
Because quantum mechanics
Oh, not quantum mechanics
I mean quantum computing
I think its main bottleneck right now
is actually in the experiments
It's not about how you design those algorithms
or design those operators
It's more about how you implement it experimentally
That's something I'm actually not good at
It's actually quite unrelated to many things
I'm interested in
It's actually relatively unrelated
On the other hand, the things related to me are more
Like AI, as I just mentioned
It's more about having an idea
and then you can use some numbers to verify it
This numerical aspect in AI
might be training a model or something like that
Right and this is actually quite similar to doing physics
It even is
That's why
I've always liked to compare this
With 18th century physics
Make comparisons
It's more like physics of that era
In that era theory and experiment weren't separated
There were no theoretical physicists
Experimental physicists
You just did physics
Just did physics
You could do experiments yourself
And also do theoretical speculation
I think AI is a bit like that era
So actually
The distance from theoretical physics to experimental physics
Is farther than directly jumping to AI
Farther, mm-hmm
Actually farther
And in terms of interest it's also farther
You don't like experimental physics
(I think) You don't like doing experiments
I think, um
It's indeed not where my interest lies
Mm-hmm although I'm not willing to do it myself
But I am indeed very interested
In knowing how other people's experiments are going
Hahahaha
Doesn't AI require doing experiments
Yes, but it's more like numerics
Right it's not quite like
That thing where you go to the lab and build an optical table
And whatnot
You also have to
I think experiments are really something
Maybe because I don't understand
I haven't reached that level
So some things seem quite mystical to me
For example
Everyone knows how to build this optical table
But some people can build it for you
Some people just can't build it after 6 years
This is hands-on ability
I just don't get it
Hahahaha
I sometimes think
This thing is a bit mystical
Oh
Mm-hmm so numerics are still better
Numerics are much clearer
Right right right, for me
Doing numerical experiments
Or like AI
Training models
And studying various different techniques
To look at certain details
This thing is actually um, is
I can understand why it's done this way
Mm-hmm but when it comes to building the table
I'm completely at a loss
You've done it before
I of course have
Everyone has probably done basic
Physics students definitely all
Done basic experimental training
But more importantly I have many friends who do experiments
Whether visiting their labs
And watching how they do experiments
Or chatting with them about how to design experiments
I feel like there are many things I can't quite understand
But indeed some of them do it well
Some don't do it well
So you say doing AI research now
Is like doing thermodynamics research in the 17th century
What it's actually expressing is
Although everyone can't very clearly
Scientifically explain and understand this thing
But it won't stop it from developing
Right it's more like
Why
Comparing to thermodynamics of that era
In that era
Everyone actually didn't understand the microscopic theory of heat
Everyone didn't know what heat was
Just like now we can't understand
Right just like now
Everyone can't understand
Which matrix element in this language model
Is doing what
Actually everyone doesn't understand
But it doesn't prevent you from having some good empirical laws
Like various laws of thermodynamics
And various Scaling Laws now
So
From this perspective it is
From this
From the perspective of this direction
Yes
At this level
It's something like
And from a researcher's perspective
It's that other point I was making
Theory and experiment actually go hand in hand
So how did you end up interviewing at Anthropic
How did your Anthropic journey unfold
I think the main thing was
I had former colleagues at Anthropic
Haha, yeah
Former colleagues
So Anthropic
actually has a lot of people from
physics backgrounds
especially theoretical physics backgrounds
Why is that
In terms of their hiring choices
why did they choose this group of people
I think
Of course, many
Mmm
A lot of people might come up with reasons like
physicists are good at this or that
But from my personal perspective
I think the main reason is still connections
Just connections
Because in Anthropic's founding team
there were actually
three or four fairly technical people at the time
and two of them
are still very much on the technical front lines
in leadership
Both of them came from physics backgrounds
And the people they might have recruited
also came from physics backgrounds
So it just continued that way
But actually, at this stage
after I joined
they barely hired anymore
people with no AI background at all. Right.
So it's also a
I think it's also a product of its era
Right, and then
Anyway, I decided to go into AI at that point
So I tried to reach out to a few places
And then
You only looked at
Anthropic?
No, I also reached out to OpenAI and GDM
That is, Google DeepMind
But Google DeepMind
because it was too slow back then
Hahaha, so I didn't
Just didn't
end up in consideration
But
Too slow
You mean their interview process was slow
But later
Obviously later
They made huge strides with Gemini
They moved really fast after that
Haha, yeah
And then Anthropic
Well, anyway
What about OpenAI
I reached out to OpenAI too
But OpenAI
probably didn't find a particularly good fit in terms of projects and people
And Anthropic was because I reached out at that time
And then it was
my first
that manager
my first manager
And he used to do theoretical physics too
And he said at the time
We're trying to do reinforcement learning
Trying to do this kind of large-scale reinforcement learning
There are many scientific questions to understand
That was in '24
Around August or September
At that time
actually
reinforcement learning wasn't as mature as it is now
Back then
most people didn't really know how to do it
Because o1 hadn't been released yet
Back then, o1 was just, yeah, yeah, yeah
It was just
Just
Everyone knew it was out there
But no one had seen the results yet
But Anthropic didn't actually know how to do it back then
They had a general idea at the time
But there were many details that needed careful study
So he told me, hey
There's this thing
Would you like to come interview
And I thought, hey
It might be a good opportunity
How did you perceive reinforcement learning back then
No clue, haha
You roughly know pre-training
Post-training, yeah, exactly
I roughly knew the pipeline
But I didn't really know the specifics of
how industrial-grade language models are trained
Mm
I only knew how it's done in academia
Right, and then
So looking back, what I knew then
In hindsight, it was basically nothing
Right, and then, mm
More than anything
I felt at the time that this was an uncertain thing
But it was a good opportunity
So I just went for it
Mm
Of course there was some interview prep and the interview process, right
How did you prepare
What did you talk about
At the time
Who did I interview with
Anthropic, some of my later colleagues interviewed then
And then
The interview questions weren't too hard
Anyway, haha, right
But for me
I didn't know how to prepare back then either
I just went through all the courses I could find
Learned everything I could on my own
Did all the assignments I could do
And then I hand-rolled a whole system myself
That Andrej Karpathy
He has that famous project called
I think it's called nanoGPT or something
Anyway, he has one where
You can train a tiny GPT model inside a Google Colab Notebook
And I hand-rolled that
And then I went to the interview
And that was it
Right
And got the offer pretty quickly
And then, right
Got the offer
And then
Your first direction was large-scale reinforcement learning
Actually, back then two teams reached out
Two team managers
Came to talk to me
One was doing evaluation
Basically model evaluation
And the other was doing reinforcement learning
I chose reinforcement learning
You chose reinforcement learning back then
Because it was more unclear, right
Mm-hm, and back then
Anthropic wasn't the big company it is now
The company was actually quite small back then
How many people
When I joined
Our big team only had about 10 people
Or 10 people
Or 11 people
What was the big team called
It was called Horizon
Right, and then
Back then that big team
So like the parallel teams to this big team
What were they
That big team later basically became
The team that covered every aspect of reinforcement learning
Right, but back then
Its whole larger group
Was just reinforcement learning
The whole larger group
Well, for a startup
It's hard to say what that group's goal was
Because
They probably had many different goals at various points
But just at that stage
The main goal was probably doing reinforcement learning
Right, and then
Of course there were also teams more focused on data below that
Teams more focused on environments and infra and infrastructure
And teams more focused on research and algorithms
And the team I joined
Was more on the research and algorithms side
Mm, how many people did Anthropic have back then
Uh, back then probably
Around seven or eight hundred in total
But the whole company
Seven or eight hundred, right
What was your first impression when you joined
I think
I think my impression of Anthropic
Has actually been pretty
Pretty consistent
I mean, after joining
My impression of the company was that it had very strong execution
It's just that
It's actually a relatively top-down company
Right and then
So after many things are decided
They go all in
And
The atmosphere between employees in the company is actually very good
Everyone
Doesn't hide things
And especially when I first joined it was very small
So
Everyone knew each other
So the atmosphere was very good
And
I think
If you're doing
Just doing language model related things
Actually looking back now
That was a very very good learning opportunity
Where you could get exposed to every aspect of
Training this model
And could find corresponding people to ask
Did Anthropic at that time already have
What we all know now
That very firm bet
Yes yes
Where did this bet come from
Why did this bet exist
I don't know its complete source
One obvious source I could see
Was the previous generation model
After Claude 3 was released
On Twitter, which might not have been called X yet
Many people on Twitter were discussing
That Claude 3 seems to write code better than GPT-4
In that era
GPT-4 was still a model with a huge gap from everyone else
So being able to do one important thing better than GPT-4
Was quite impressive
So it was discovered through trial
I think at least that's one of the reasons
It was very quick feedback on the market
Right, this is also something I think this company is very strong at
Its execution is very very strong
Once it gets a signal
That makes it feel very reasonable
Something this company should do
Then it will go all in
It doesn't have that redundancy of large organizations
Why was its coding definitely better than GPT-4
Can't say haha
Oh there is a reason
There is a reason
There is a reason, right
But it's a random reason
Not because I chose this
So this result happened
It's a purely technical reason
But
Indeed, I don't
I can't determine whether it was randomly tried at first
Or deliberately chosen
If you ask me to guess
I would definitely think it was randomly tried
Oh
A purely technical reason
There was someone who did something
There was indeed a certain team that did something
Was it top-down
Or bottom-up
I think at first it might have been bottom-up
But later it became a top-down thing
To quickly capture some market
Right, internal and market signals
Right right
I think this is
Need to quickly go all in
Right right
I think this is something Anthropic is very very strong at
It's very very reactive
Reacts very quickly
Where does its execution come from
Comes from this person Dario
Comes from his certain trait
I feel like
Mm-hmm Anthropic
As a company
It can implement this
Relatively top-down mechanism
Is a very unique thing
Why
Because
Implementing top-down actually has one very difficult point
That the person making technical decisions
Must also be the company's decision maker
Mm-hmm
First of all you have to be technically convincing
Then the researchers below will
You can then
Convince the researchers below to do this thing
On the other hand, you have to be the decision-maker at the company
You have to be able to take responsibility for the company
Anthropic has that going for it
That is, its technical leader
Is actually a cofounder of the company
Who are you referring to?
Not Dario Amodei
Like Jared Kaplan
And Sam McCandlish
And both of them are cofounders of the company
They make this decision themselves
It's their company
So they have the authority to do this top-down
Then Dario, as CEO
Does he get to say yes or no?
I don't know about their decision-making discussions
Hahaha, okay
What role did Dario play?
I can only say
The technical leader has the decision-making power
For my work at that time
The person I worked with the most was Jared
But is this hard for other model companies?
Very hard. For example, OpenAI couldn't do it
When Ilya was
there, wasn't it possible?
When Ilya was there, it might have been possible
But Ilya later, on one hand
I don't know for what reason
He seemed to have lost the ability to make decisions
And then he left
So...
What about other companies?
I think other companies all find it pretty difficult
Even Gemini finds it pretty difficult
But I think Gemini has a completely different playbook
It's a bit different
That is, um
I think big companies and startups
Their playbooks are fundamentally different
Because for startups, what's important is to make bets
That is, I have to bet on something
If I want to bet
It means there's risk
So that means
I can make decisions very quickly
And push decisions through strongly
So perhaps in this situation
Top-down is a big advantage, I think
So I think organizationally, Anthropic
Has an advantage over OpenAI
But as a big company
It might have a different mindset
Because a big company's mindset might be
Not only can I minimize the gambling aspect
But I can also have reserves in every area
And then if anything succeeds
I can catch up
And if I succeed at something myself
I might even take the lead
That's probably the big company mindset
So at Gemini
Google is a very traditional
Very bottom-up organization
At the company level
There may be some well-defined frameworks
To evaluate whether your work is good or bad
To guide you to do things the company needs
But essentially
It's still you deciding what you do yourself
So you think Anthropic can make bets (referring to betting heavily on coding)
Because of its unique culture
Organization and culture, yes
This sounds like
Something other companies should be able to do too
But it's very strangely found that
Other companies find it hard to do
While Anthropic can do it
Yes, I think it still requires technical credibility
Or the company's leaders need to have credibility
I think this is actually quite difficult
You're not even talking about the CEO having credibility
It's the #1 technical person having credibility
Yes, to me
I think it's very important for the #1 technical person to have credibility
But at the same time
The CEO may not have become an obstacle
Yes
Is this hard?
Ah, I think it depends on your
This cofounding team
Whether there's enough mutual trust
This is also crucial
I think Anthropic is also strong in this regard
Very strong among startups
Its cofounding team
Not a single person has left the company
If you look at their past
They are a group of people who have truly fought battles together
In the past
They originated from, they were all former OpenAI employees
Mm-hmm right
And
Many of them were even
Co-authors on a series of key papers
Co-authors, because like
The Scaling Law paper
Was Jared Kaplan and Sam
And of course Dario
And some others
Maybe Tom Brown was there too
I can't quite remember if Tom Brown was there
And the GPT-3 paper had Tom Brown
And Benjamin Mann
And Jared Kaplan and Sam were both there
Dario was also there
So they are people who have been in the trenches together
I think mutual trust is still very key
Mm-hmm, many companies might just be doing their thing
And can't even keep this small group united
Then how can you expect
This big company to stay united
You're talking about OpenAI right
Mm-hmm, hahaha
When you joined Anthropic
What was the most important
Project the company was working on
Did you participate in that big project
Right
At that time the goal was to do large-scale
Large-scale reinforcement learning
And use it to improve coding ability
That was the most important thing at that time
Mm-hmm and we were doing this
This team
The research focus at that time was this thing
This is also why this team later gradually grew bigger
And became more and more important
And
The final result was
Everyone trained this 3.7 together
The Claude 3.7 model
Hey you said internally there was a 3.6
This is
Not internally called
It's from the outside
Claude 3.5 actually had two versions
One might be the June version
Another October version, and then
You can also see
Anthropic this company
Used to have no product capability either
Actually calling two models by one name
Hahahaha
So later outsiders to distinguish
Called the later version of 3.5 as 3.6
So Anthropic followed this outside convention
And called it 3.6
Called this newer model 3.7
So
If you look at the actual product timeline of this company
It's actually 3.5, 3.5new, 3.7
How could there be a 3.5new
What were they thinking
Haha
I can only say
Anthropic at that time
Probably really had no product ideas
So your first project was 3.7 or 3.5
3.7, 3.7
Or 3.5new
3.5new
Actually I
Didn't participate, almost didn't participate
But 3.5new
Already showed signs of coding
Really? When you first started
At the time of 3.5new
Already saw
Anthropic's model
Would be stronger than other models in agentic coding
Why is that
Can't say hahaha
So when you went in
It was exactly when
They knew about this thing
That management also knew about this sign
Right and when they wanted to make bets
You had very good luck I think
I think, right
I think when I joined
Everyone had definitely already seen
This thing could be done and was important
But didn't quite know how to do it
And when I went in
I was researching with everyone how to do it
Right so the method was large-scale reinforcement learning
Right from the big picture perspective
But of course
There are many technical details that need to be researched
What know-how is in here
Haha there are lots of NDA (Non-Disclosure Agreement) contents
Hahaha
Would NDAs be written in such detail
Actually in principle
In principle
Employees cannot during their employment and after leaving
Disclose any information related to the company's internals
Of course in reality
Everyone probably has a sense of degree in their mind
That is
If this technology hasn't been made public
Definitely won't discuss it publicly
But I think although I can't discuss it publicly
But
I think
Doing simple things cleaner than anyone else
Is the most critical thing
What do you mean by clean
You also used this word just now
Right it's it's
I think there are many fancy techniques
For example doing reinforcement learning
The simplest algorithm is Policy Gradient
But that doesn't mean it's the only algorithm
There are other algorithms
Like various complex
Search algorithms and such
But
Are these complexities necessary
And these complexities might bring you
Some efficiency
That is efficiency improvements
But they might bring you some
For example
Infrastructure difficulties
Then how do you trade off these things
These things actually need to be understood in research
How to balance these different factors
And choose the best path
The most stable path
Right and I think a lot of know-how
Is actually in these
These details
How to handle all these aspects of details
Then how was coding described as important at that time
I think
Is it considered a branch of large language models
An important branch
Or what
I think everyone might have different ideas
For me
There are two reasons it's important
One reason is
What Anthropic has been talking about
That coding itself
Is also part of language model research
If you can do coding very well
It might make your research efficiency
Improve by multiples
Mm-hmm, forming a research flywheel
This is one reason
For me
Another reason
Is because coding is actually a model
Using tools and interacting with the environment
A very good abstraction
First of all the benefits of this abstraction
What are the benefits of this abstraction
For example the feedback signal is clear
And data is abundant
And
Actually it's very hard in other scenarios
To find
Tool-using scenarios that have both these traits simultaneously
So for me this is a good abstraction
Some research done in this area
Might be useful for more general
Those abilities to use tools and interact with the environment
Some useful
Useful lessons
What was Cursor's status at that time
At that time Cursor was still a
Pure product company
I think in a sense
It seems like before I went to Anthropic
During that period
Claude and Cursor were both in relatively underdog states
And somehow at 3.5new, which is 3.6
The outside world's 3.6 generation
First the model capability went up
Then Cursor discovered
This model
Could really do this kind of Agentic coding tool
It's just a shell
Right but this shell wrapping this model
Suddenly let the public experience
Not the public
The public here means the software engineering community
At that time, um
I realized
Wow, this really seems like a productivity tool
So after that, it just took off
So around that time
Anthropic realized
Cursor is a future competitor
I don't know about that
You'd have to ask Dario, hahahaha, alright
How was 3.7 made
This was a watershed moment
For Anthropic
It was a watershed model
I think for Anthropic's post-training
It was a watershed
Before 3.7
Post-training was in a relatively
Um
Small-scale
And
It was more like patching things up
That kind of state for the model
People didn't value post-training, right?
It's not that they didn't value it
Everyone from the start
For a long time
No one really figured out
How post-training should scale up
Oh, but during that period
Whether OpenAI or Anthropic
Or even like China's DeepSeek, right
They realized how to scale this up
And how to scale it up
You have to find
The right environment
Where the feedback signal is clear enough
And the environment itself is a strong data source
And then
On top of that
You can make the training very stable
Then it can work
Yeah, I remember back then
Actually no one knew
What OpenAI's secret project was
Just knew it was called Strawberry
Called Strawberry
And then, um
People thought it would bring a new paradigm
A new paradigm of post-training reinforcement learning
But no one knew much more than that
Yeah, actually
I think when I joined Anthropic
People already had a pretty good idea
About how this should roughly be done
The general direction of how to do it
And then
Later on, as time went on
As I learned more and more about this field
I discovered
At that moment
The way OpenAI was doing things
And Anthropic were actually quite different
How so?
In terms of the specific algorithms
And the way they used data
They were actually quite different
Although both are called post-training and reinforcement learning
Um, although both are called that
But of course I don't think those are the fundamental differences
In terms of the big picture
They're the same
They found some
Found some very regression-like
Very clear signals
Very objective
And the data itself is relatively clean
And learnable for the model
And do stable reinforcement learning training on top of it
In the big picture, that's the direction
But the specific implementations differ quite a lot
But later it was proven
The specific implementation
Each company actually went in different directions
But they all succeeded
Um, and at the time OpenAI's goal wasn't coding either
From what I understood, the narrative was
Pre-training as the first paradigm
The gold mine is almost exhausted
So now we're opening a second gold mine
Which is post-training and reinforcement learning
To let the Scaling Law continue, right
I think for a long time
OpenAI had this idea
I don't know if their thinking has changed now
For me
My thinking has gone through shifts
Around the era of 3.7
I actually felt like I
At that time I also had the feeling that pre-training was almost
Party is over
This kind of feeling
And right when you were about to join
Right when I first joined
And at that time when doing these 3.7 related
These kinds of experiments
I also once had this idea
But later as my understanding deepened
I felt I discovered
Actually there's still room to do things
And um
Pre-training Scaling Law
It doesn't tell you to keep getting bigger
It's actually a very systematic framework
That can tell you what kinds of things are more effective
Right, mm-hmm
And
So later discovered
Actually there are still many things to do
The fact is
Later Anthropic
And Gemini's pre-training
Have also been continuously progressing
OpenAI itself was stuck for a long time
Haha, are they paying attention to pre-training again now
They should have been paying attention to pre-training for quite a while
It's just recently they might have made some progress
So pre-training and post-training as two paradigms
Neither has reached its plateau
I think neither has
But you say predicting how far it will go
Can't do that
Right I think
I think reaching a plateau has
Two possibilities
One possibility is the technology itself has reached
Where you still have things you want the model to do
But these two technologies just can't teach it
Another possibility is
The things you want to do have reached a plateau
I think now it's the latter
Right now we know oh
There's a Chatbot
You can teach it to do this
And then there's coding
And then we don't know
Right, don't know what else to teach it
That is to say
This model is still a very smart kid
Right you can actually teach it many things
Right but we humans as teachers
Now don't know what the next thing to teach is
Right right
Or how to reasonably teach it
Using current paradigms
Speaking of 3.7, what other know-how
How many months did this take
This finally all in all
From starting training to release
Probably took about four or five months
From when you first joined
From when everyone started
Doing research for this thing
That probably took two or three months
And then later from starting training to training completion
With bumps along the way
Many things to handle
And there was a lot of new infrastructure
Actually infrastructure is really important
Very time-consuming
And then probably took about two months or so
What important work did you do in it
I don't think I did anything important
Hahaha
I think
My personal contribution
I personally
My contribution to any model
My statement
Is always
I feel like I'm not that important to that thing
I think more importantly I was very lucky
To have the opportunity
To join an important project at that time
And did some things
Mm-hmm, because in a sense
I think AI in recent years
This thing itself is unstoppable
It doesn't depend on whether you do it or not
If you don't do it someone else can do it just as well
So I think in this era
Actually all things that give individuals credit
Are somewhat hyped
Suspicious
Of being hyped
But indeed I think for me
I am very lucky
Being able to join at that stage was a big deal
And, well, I learned a few things
So you were lucky to be there at that stage
At Anthropic
this company's
large-scale reinforcement learning team
what did you do
I think around the 3.7 era, what we mainly worked on was still
working on this agentic coding thing
how to scale this thing up
or how to prepare
like how to set up
all kinds of environments and data
including what algorithmic problems you'd run into
Most of the research at the time was on this part
Any tips on this?
Looking back, there aren't really any particularly useful tips, haha
I think
When it comes to technical tips
this is actually something
that on one hand, people are really eager to hear about
but companies won't let you talk about
and in reality isn't very useful
Why?
Because a lot of algorithm design isn't actually independent
independent of the algorithm itself
It's very strongly
dependent on your infrastructure
A simple example is
some companies
there's a problem people often discuss
which is during reinforcement learning
the sample（采样） machine, the one that generates these
these trace（轨迹）
these token(词元) — that machine and the trainer(训练器)
used to actually train the model
and then update the model weights — that machine
these two machines might be different
But the difference
is partly due to numerical differences
and partly because
of using this kind of asynchronous training architecture
so naturally
fundamentally they're different
So different companies might have different
degrees of this difference
so your algorithm design will also differ
Some companies might have these two differences
being very, very large
then the biggest part of your algorithm might be
how to control this
and how to keep the training stable
Things like the actual training effectiveness
will be weighted slightly less
But some companies might
have particularly excellent infrastructure
so the difference between these two isn't that big
then you can probably spend more effort
on the training effectiveness
So a lot of these small tips
are actually not very useful
A lot of know-how is actually not very useful
I say this because I've indeed noticed
that many
other labs — well, not
people in these three labs probably really want to know
like how Anthropic does this
or how Gemini does that
But sometimes I'm reluctant to answer
One main reason
is that fundamentally I think
answering this question would mislead them
Modern AI training is a large system
You actually need to understand
all aspects of this system
to have a holistic understanding
of what makes something useful because of what
rather than saying the thing itself is useful
What happened from 3.7 to 4.5?
Both pre-training and post-training, yes
And, um
Of course it's just
more scaling up
And data
Whether it's data or training
the compute is at a much larger scale
But I think in terms of paradigm, there wasn't
anything particularly major that changed
How many people was it when you left Anthropic?
Close to 2,000, I think
More than doubled
Ah, um
So during your time at Anthropic
it happened to be going through its most dramatic transformation
Ah, I probably just caught
the tail end of it being a small company
Actually, I think after three
or four months, the company already started
and suddenly there were way more people
Did the culture change?
There were still some rather chaotic phases
And then
Especially around the time when I left
The period right before I left
I think culturally, it went through some
some chaos
Because some people came in from outside
and there was probably some conflict with the original culture
Oh, the previous culture was
I think before, it was just
pretty simple
Yeah, it was very simple
It was
more like a small workshop
Everyone was friends
And everyone knew what the others were doing
And
No one was particularly
you know, doing
too much self-promotion or anything like that
Doing pointless things
No one was doing pointless things
Everyone had a lot on their plate
And the company back then
probably had a stronger sense of urgency
And later on, people probably felt that
with more people
this kind of culture would definitely take some hits
What kind of atmosphere did it bring?
I think
There were indeed some people I personally didn't like very much
Of course, that doesn't mean they're actually bad
I'm just saying I personally didn't like them
I mean, I probably don't like
people who talk a lot in this field
Like, I think 'idea is cheap'
Ideas are cheap
Many ideas
are actually quite obvious, everyone knows them
The hard part is how to implement them
How to break it down into small
actionable steps
and actually get it done
I don't think I like those
who spend a large part of their day
on Slack, I mean Slack
is a workplace software used in the US
and spending a lot of time on Slack
talking about grand principles
I think it's just
not very useful, haha
Why did you suddenly leave later on?
Had you completed some milestone at the time?
How long had you been thinking about it?
At the time, I think I'd been thinking about it for
a month or two
about a month or so
a little over a month
That was fast, yeah yeah
I think one aspect was
Um, it was
I actually didn't really agree with Dario's anti-China stance
Ah, I think as a company CEO
For him personally
whatever views he holds, I think it's fine
But as a company CEO
I think
pushing this view to such an extreme
was a very emotional reaction
Yeah, and this was a relatively minor reason
But on the bigger picture
There are many companies
Like I just mentioned
There were some cultural shocks at the company
And including myself
I probably wanted to learn some different things
I mean, Anthropic
is after all very focused
And you might be doing
If you really want to work on everything related to language
models in all aspects
And
working on this kind of tool use, this Agentic stuff
and coding and such
then Anthropic is actually great
You can learn a lot
But there are many things Anthropic doesn't do
For example, no one at Anthropic is doing
this kind of multimodal generation
You want to learn but there's nowhere to learn it
And Anthropic probably didn't spend too much energy
on this kind of more low-level
engineering
infrastructure
Right
So probably wanting to learn more things
was also one of my motivations for leaving at the time
What percentage was the anti-China stance?
Because of Dario's personal reasons
I've in public
Combined say 40%
But this number anyway just listen to it
This number just tells you
It's not the main reason
But it is indeed a very big reason
Not controlling
Not a controlling reason
Right not a controlling reason
But it's a majority holder reason
Your choice is also quite amazing
Because most people
When it's still an underdog
Joining will create more emotional attachment
Willing to accompany the company for a longer time
But you instead jumped to Google
Because many researchers once they enter Google
They feel Google doesn't give enough scope
Mm-hmm
So they instead want to jump to places like xAI
Or smaller organizations like Anthropic
Your move seems to be the opposite
Right I think
Actually depends on what you yourself want
If what you really want is I have a very clear
Like you said a very clear scope
And this thing
Is closely related to my final product model
I must get one of my ideas
Into this model
Then Google might be a very bad place
Because after all there are so many researchers
So many already mature organizations
Doing this thing
Has a very complicated process
But I think Gemini is very
If what you want is research freedom
Freedom to explore
And want to learn from broader humanity
I think in this world
You probably can't find a second place stronger than Gemini
So
So it's
I think
Essentially it still depends on what you yourself want
But I think many people when they leave
Regardless of where they leave from
After switching to another place
The main reason they might feel unhappy
Is because they didn't figure out what they wanted
For example if you came to Google
But told me
At first you thought you wanted research freedom
And more motivation was learning
And after you went
Discovered you still wanted product impact
Then you might feel very uncomfortable haha
You don't pursue impact
You also said this
Now AI is a very large system
And is a
Very large collaborative effort
What are you pursuing in it
I think it's divided into stages
I think
At Anthropic
After experiencing too much
Product-related things
I might also want to change my mindset
To learn some different things
But you say is there any day
I might switch back to this mindset
And want to produce some product influence
That's also possible
How do you quantify product influence
This is very clear internally
Really
Hard to quantify
I think
Because when publishing papers there was still first author
This kind of lead author
Now
Mm-hmm actually there's no way to quantify
The reality is there's no way to quantify
This is also why I think in this era
Actually talking about each individual's influence
Is a very very ethereal thing
I think essentially it's still the organization that did
Such a thing
Or the world needs this
So producing product impact is a subjective feeling
At least on the model side it is
Right and then
Of course actually you can
I think you can
The details are about what things you yourself have done
Specific technical contributions
And the effects produced technically
This can be discussed objectively
But more subjective things are
You were saying
how much did this effect account for in the final product
No one can really say for sure
Can you describe what you did on 3.7
What kind of technical work did you do
that actually had an impact on the model
It was mainly related to agentic coding
and the environment around it
And some algorithmic work as well
On the algorithmic side, it was mainly about making the training more
stable
To be honest
But I do think there were definitely some algorithmic improvements
but they didn't achieve particularly ideal results
To be honest
It's definitely better than the previous algorithms
Yeah
But I don't think that was my personal contribution
I think it was a collective effort from everyone, haha
Right, every time I ask you
you always say it's a collective effort
It's not an era of individual heroism anymore
Right, I think the era of individual heroism
for language models
has probably passed
When was it?
It was the Transformer moment
Right, at that point when the technology
hadn't yet reached the scale-up stage
The person who discovered that technology
might be a hero
Or a small group that discovered it
might be heroes
After that technology was found
for probably a long time
from the model side, it's all been
I think more about collectivism
whether this group can work together
whether they can toward a common goal
spending their own time together
and their own energy
That's the most important thing
Rather than what each individual
contributed
The reason you say collectivism
is because the capability actually comes from AI, is that right?
The reason I say collectivism
is because I think AI as a field is fundamentally simple
Like
I don't think there's any
Except maybe that leap moment
where the idea might require
some really deep insights
In the process after that
many ideas are actually very trivial (微不足道的)
Very stupid, basically
Anyone could think of them
Anyone could do them
It's just that you got lucky
and happened to seize the opportunity to do it
Including when you described Anthropic
doing coding, it seemed like there was some randomness to it too
But you have to seize it
Right, right. But I think when it comes to coding
it might still involve more
than the technical stuff on the model side
a bit more corporate heroism, perhaps
That is, whether you can bet on it fast enough
Yeah, Anthropic was indeed very strong in that regard
But if Anthropic hadn't done it today
some other company probably would have
I think so. It's inevitable
So it's all about emergent capabilities in AI
It's just about whether you can seize that capability
Whether it's a company or an individual
Right, right
I think before usable language models
before large-scale language models emerged
a lot of things were not inevitable
Like whether someone could invent something
whether a language model could be trained at scale
and whether the GPT paradigm
could be discovered
There was a lot of uncertainty
But like you said, for example
if there had been no Google Brain back then
Transformer might not have been discovered
It might have taken many, many years
before another well-funded organization with talented people discovered it
That would have been a huge impact
But after entering that stage
especially now, the situation has reversed
Any organization that wants to stop AI progress
can't do it
Anthropic has
Anthropic is very concerned about AI safety
But does Anthropic have the ability to stop AI development?
It doesn't
If you stop developing
Others will continue
Your voice will only get smaller
Right, actually right now it's
It's more like this kind of situation
The world is pushing us forward
Rather than us pushing the world forward
I feel like in the future it'll be even harder for us to stop AI
Haha, I think we already can't stop it
I just think
Trying to prevent one specific thing from happening with AI
Probably isn't the right mindset to begin with
This also relates to what we were just talking about
Because we were just talking about Anthropic
One of Anthropic's very important motivations
Is so-called AI safety
I think when it comes to AI safety
The motivation when it was founded
Right
What does that have to do with it now
The relationship now is complicated, meaning
A natural
Question people might ask is
A company focused on AI safety
Why is it now training frontier models
Anthropic's explanation is that
First, I need to have the most cutting-edge model
Only then do I have a voice to push my AI safety agenda
So actually, its thinking all along has been
I want to build the best model in the world
Everyone will have to listen to me
To push forward my safety policies
But from my personal perspective
I think this idea is very naive
Looking at this now
It's not going to happen
What's more likely to happen is
Everyone will have great frontier models
And you won't be able to stop anything from happening
Maybe for this issue
What we should focus on and think more about now is
If you really want to avoid AI
Bringing about some crisis
What would be a more self-enforcing approach
Let me give an example of a self-enforcing mechanism
Like nuclear weapons, for example
Nuclear weapons are also something that everyone thinks, hey
This might have the power to destroy the world
But with nuclear weapons, in the end
The way they were ultimately controlled
Is multi-party control
In this world
There are many countries with nuclear weapons
They all have the ability to destroy each other
So stability is maintained through this kind of balance of power
I think if you want to stop AI from doing bad things
Maybe
Ultimately, you'll need a similar mechanism to achieve that
Rather than hoping
Pinning your hopes on
One company setting a law to do something
Mm, right
And it sets it itself
It can only govern itself
Mm, you also just mentioned
Anthropic has an interpretability team
Right
How far has their interpretability gotten
In some relatively simple
Relatively sparse neural networks
They can do some interesting research
For example
Look at what a certain output
Or input text or image
What its internal representation looks like
And then maybe you invert that representation somehow
What kind of thing it can output after that
Doing this kind of research
You also just mentioned a viewpoint
That AI is essentially simple
Can you describe what you mean by this
This is a conclusion
Right, I think this is
This isn't even a conclusion
It's just my statement（陈述）
It's my statement
It could be right or wrong
Oh, and my explanation for this
This is your view
Right, my explanation for this
My explanation for this statement is
I think the reason it's essentially simple is
That you can run experiments
Like, compared to things that are fundamentally difficult
Like physics, for example
The difference is
With that
Without experimental data at that energy scale
You simply can't understand the theory at that energy scale
But AI isn't bound by this（约束）
It doesn't matter if you don't understand it
It can still move forward
And also right now
The fact is
I can do any experiment I can think of
It's just that possibly
I need some time
To scale up the compute
Or get the infrastructure ready
But there's no fundamental difficulty
Right
So I've always been saying
I feel AI doesn't give people the sense
That it's hitting a wall because
First, you can try many things
Second
It's not that everyone has run out of ideas
With no ideas left to try
More often it's that there are too many ideas
Need to try them one by one
Take time
Mm-hmm
Feels like humans are so insignificant
In front of these experiments
Yes, so
I think very soon
AI might start doing experiments itself
How soon is very soon
Within 4 months
I think in the next 6-12 months
AI will do experiments itself
I think of course this statement
Is not very well-defined
Sorry I said something very vague
Like um
AI improving itself
Or speeding up its own development process
This is actually already happening
Right
Like we discussed earlier
It's already helping us
To achieve some of the things we want
And speed up our experimental pace
But I think in the next six to twelve
Sorry
What it currently can't do is
Whether it can
From start to finish complete an AI research project
Like not only can it write this code
It can also run this experiment
Run this experiment
Can also see the results
See the results
Can also analyze the results
Analyze the results
Know where it did wrong
Then propose new hypotheses
Design new code
Run new experiments
This chain is not yet complete
But I think
This chain
Might be the next thing to gradually become complete
Based on your various reasons
At the moment you left
Decided to leave Anthropic
What were your expectations for this company's future
I think when I left
I was actually quite pessimistic about this company
But later obviously I was overly pessimistic
Hehehe why pessimistic
The reason I was pessimistic at that time was
I think when I left Anthropic
Anthropic actually um
Its main revenue source was API
Selling tokens
And
This is a bad business
Is a bad business
Because this business
Is only a good business for one company
Which is Google
Because this
This business eventually leads to price wars
Eventually it will be price wars
In price wars if you don't have the complete chain
There's not much advantage
But later Anthropic obviously on the product side
I think indeed there were many clever ideas
Did many good things
Whether it's Claude Code getting better and better
And Claude Cowork
And various
Work and efficiency related things
All slowly converged
So it feels like it has now become more than
What I thought at the time
If you ask me which of OpenAI and Anthropic would die first
Of course they won't really die
Just which would become less important first
At that time I would think hey
Maybe Anthropic would become less important first
But later first OpenAI got punched by Google
Then Anthropic itself got on track
So now it seems Anthropic has more advantage
Haha
Have you ever regretted it
Mm-hmm not really
I think for me personally
My personal motivation was still wanting to switch places
Improve myself
I think for this
For the thing I wanted to do
This choice wasn't wrong
You also mentioned Anthropic's products have many clever ideas
Especially this year
Like Cowork and such
Where does this come from
I think I didn't see Cowork's development process
So I don't know
And Claude Code
I think the person, the product
Might also
Really have some opportunities for individual heroism
Is it a researcher or a product manager
Boris Cherny
I think Claude Code almost
At least the beginning of this thing
Was him wanting to do this thing himself
To improve his own or colleagues' work efficiency
Finally became something
Important to everyone
What kind of person is Boris
I didn't have too much personal contact with him
I mostly just saw his work, when at the company
He's a researcher right
Right but he's mainly on the product side
So Anthropic does have a dedicated product department
Didn't used to be so separated
Later had a separate one
Right, Anthropic seems to really understand AI products
Right I think
I think this is why
When we first started talking
Felt that product managers
Might still be quite hard to replace with AI currently
Hahaha mm-hmm
Good product managers
Hey he doesn't seem to be the previous generation of product managers
He's not the kind who arranges features and such
He seems to know how to collaborate with AI
Some kind of product manager
Right I think the previous generation of product managers might
But not entirely
The previous generation also had some
Interaction
Interaction-level changes
But every interaction-level change
Actually brings a very big product
Like maybe Douyin
Is a product with interaction-level change
Then it immediately brought huge
Mm-hmm opened new directions
And I think
Maybe Claude Code is also a product at this level
Claude Code and Cowork were both by Boris
I don't know who did Cowork
OK I already left
I see
Then tell me about after you arrived at Google
DeepMind, has your work focus changed
Work focus changed or not
Mm-hmm, still
Some changes happened
And
I anyway mainly focus on
Doing ML coding
And some relatively long horizon things
These two things
其实刚才都都大概提了一嘴
Like ML coding
Actually just now both were roughly mentioned
Actually it mainly wants to achieve
The complete AI training itself process we just talked about
Of course in this process
There are many practical problems
Many practical details to solve
I think in the big picture
Everyone actually has quite a consensus on how to do it
But still back to details
There are many things to handle in details
Like how to choose appropriate data
How to choose appropriate feedback signals
And it brings new infrastructure challenges
And
Now it's about slowly figuring out these things
Slowly figuring them out
And
Like long horizon
Is the other thing we just talked about
That is wanting to achieve
That this model can
Still that slogan
Train with finite
But use as infinite
I think wanting to make this training
Length longer and longer and longer
Might not be making a single training
This segment's length keep increasing
Might not be a very realistic solution
But a very realistic thing is
How do you under limited context
Do longer work
Actually if you think about it
Humans are actually like this
Human context is actually very very short
If you ask me now what I ate last night
I can't remember at all
Ah you might still remember
Hahaha I can't remember at all
Because why
Because it's not critical to my current scenario
Right
Like even if I knew what I ate last night
So what
So I choose to forget it
So human context is essentially very short
But they can selectively forget
And selectively retrieve
To bring back these important
Information relevant to the current scenario
So
I think that might also be for me
A very interesting direction
These two things are actually somewhat related
Somewhat complementary
Why, these two things
Actually both are within the large category of models using tools and with environment
And different models
Different people interacting
Within this category
The node everyone completed in the past
Is Agentic coding, which is both tools and environment
Environment is this virtual machine
Or interacting within your own computer
And this thing
Actually horizontally it grows different usage scenarios
Then doing AI research
Is actually horizontally
Another scenario in this scenario
This scenario
Actually not only horizontally is it a new scenario
Vertically
It also makes the scale of this thing longer
Because completing a code completion or something
Is a very quick thing
But doing a complete AI research
Or doing this kind of computer science research
Is a very long process
Right so
It's actually like a T-shape
Horizontal extension
Vertical extension too
Is long horizon still a scientific problem
Mm-hmm there are scientific problems
Also engineering problems
I think its scientific problems are more about
How to try different solutions
After trying in a more scientific way
To find the path we ultimately want to take
This solution
What are the ways
Mm-hmm
I might not be able to say too specifically
But broadly speaking
Some solutions are from the pre-train perspective
From the pre-training perspective
Some solutions
Are similar to this sparse attention
Sparse attention
For example DeepSeek also has some work
And academia also has a lot of work
And from the post-training perspective
Also have post-training solutions
Like for example externally
Like what you use every day, Cursor and such
They have very strong context management
Managing this context ability
Like it can let the model choose
I think this middle segment is unimportant
Just throw it away
And that segment is important so store it in some file
Retrieve it when needed
These two broadly speaking
These two solutions
Both have people researching
Of course the specific implementation details
Are more than the examples I just mentioned
The examples I just mentioned
Are relatively public examples
The specific implementation details
Of course each company has its own little secrets
Well, I think ultimately it all comes down to that
And then
I personally spend a lot of
more time on post-training approaches
Because
Well, first of all,
because I myself
haven't actually spent official work time on pre-training
Pre-training is more of an interest to me
something I want to learn about
But I myself
haven't actually done that much work on it
And on the other hand,
I think post-training approaches
actually align better with my own understanding of this
My understanding of this
is exactly what we've been talking about
whether you can train with short context
but still handle long-context tasks
Pre-training approaches
essentially still require you to have long context
Training it requires the data to contain it
Right, yeah.
Right, right. So
so it doesn't quite fit my philosophy on this problem
Oh, right.
So do you think it's possible now?
Training for long with short
I think
It's definitely possible
but we're not sure which approach works best
Gemini does long-context really well
Why is that?
There are some tricks
[laughter]
There are some tricks that really surprised me, haha
Oh, this is about pre-training, right?
Doing long context well
definitely requires both sides
But I'm just saying, for me,
the pre-training side
that trick still really surprised me
[laughter]
Right, OpenAI doesn't do it as well as Gemini
on long context
But there are also different opinions
Some people say that with this Gemini 3 generation
long context actually got a bit worse
and stuff like that. Right.
Again, when you joined Gemini
it felt like people didn't have high expectations for Gemini
No, I already had pretty high expectations for Gemini at the time
Haha, what year and month was that?
I joined at the end of September last year
That was before Gemini
released Gemini 3
You had high expectations for it
What about others?
I think people in the industry
still had a pretty good impression of Gemini back then
I mean, I think
before, everyone thought Google was in real trouble
under OpenAI's impact
I think people's perception
probably shifted with the Gemini 2.5 generation
Because 2.5 was clearly
you could tell Google was getting the hang of it
Of course, even before that, Gemini's
1.5 also had some, you know,
small things
where it was already pretty strong in specific areas
It was clearly no longer far behind
But 2.5 was really
truly a generation
I think it was when people actually started using the model
Anyway, I myself have used 2.5 quite a bit
used it quite a lot
You went to Gemini because you saw 2.5?
My going to Gemini had nothing to do with that
Mainly it's because I knew
what kind of atmosphere Gemini had
There were a lot of people doing different kinds of research
And I also knew some people
actually
doing really interesting research
And many Gemini engineers
I think their technical skills are extremely, extremely strong
I think
I learned so, so much from them
And, um,
that's the reason for me
But I think from everyone's perception
I think people in the industry, after seeing Gemini 2.5
probably realized
that Gemini was catching up
So for you
that wasn't a signal for you to join Gemini, right?
It wasn't a signal for me to join
Then why did you join Gemini?
Well, like I just said,
Mainly because I wanted to accomplish something back then
Actually, I wanted to have that
But you know
Gemini has strong people
Right? Yeah, exactly
It's because when they came
When they approached me, they'd definitely want me to
Go talk to their people, right?
So from those conversations
You can actually get a sense of how things are
Oh, so they came to you
Yeah
But I think in the end it became a two-way street
So, hahaha
Wasn't OpenAI an option for you back then?
If you wanted to leave Anthropic
OpenAI was also an option at the time
OpenAI should still have been stronger than Gemini
In terms of momentum, right?
At that time
But
Though back then
Weren't there all those internal politics
Infighting was starting to emerge
I think so
So OpenAI was indeed an option for me back then
And of course there were also options like xAI
And I think
The main reason I didn't end up at OpenAI
Was that I had concerns about its
Culture, at least at that time
I had pretty big concerns about its culture
I just felt that
To put it bluntly, people who actually get things done
There weren't as many as at Gemini
Even fewer than at Anthropic
Right? I really care about that
Hahaha, yeah
So a sense of cultural and personal connection brought you to Gemini
Yeah
And then you also caught that Gemini 3 inflection point, right?
Hmm
Gemini 3 should have been a major turning point for them
A turning point period, right?
I think in terms of actual impact
I think it was two things
That created a major turning point for Gemini
Turning it into a heavyweight
player in the market
The player is Nano Banana
Nano Banana and Gemini 3
Two things back to back, which is
I think if there were only Gemini 3
It probably wouldn't have had such great results
Because when your market share is less than
Even 10%
Whether your model is slightly better or worse
It just spreads too slowly
But what Nano Banana did was
First, it went viral in the market, it was a huge hit
Then a ton of people downloaded the Gemini app
And then Gemini 3 was released right after
Retaining those users
So
Now it's become a major player
I think if Gemini hadn't thrown this punch
OpenAI's position would be really comfortable
Its market share is so high that
Whatever you do with the model
It doesn't actually matter that much to them
To be honest
I think when ordinary people use models
Their perception of the model's capabilities
Is actually very, very weak
Most people don't even use the o-series models
Most people just use the regular
ChatGPT one
Right, so I think for Genimi
This Nano Banana built up the user volume
And then Gemini 3 retained those users
Was something critical
How many ChatGPT users did it actually take away?
Hmm, I don't know the exact numbers now
But my feeling is
Gemini's market share is probably around 20%
But I haven't really checked the current data carefully
Looking at it with hindsight
These two factors
Together contributed to Gemini's challenge to OpenAI today
So from an insider's perspective you must have known earlier
What happened and why
Google would undergo such changes
Yeah, I think
First of all, Google's technical reserves
Have always been sufficient
Hmm, enough talent
Yeah, they've always been sufficient
And then
Organizationally speaking
It became increasingly clear later on
It's having a better framework to let
Everyone work together on this thing
So there might slowly be some progress
Right and then
I think in a sense
As an outsider
In a sense
I think OpenAI saved Google's life
Oh because everyone used to worry
This chatbot
Would completely replace search
Right if this really happened
Google would actually be in a tough spot
But fortunately
OpenAI did this thing first
Then made Google realize this thing is important
But it didn't take this thing all the way
Didn't take this thing to the extreme
Didn't completely kill off search
Maybe just ate some market share
As a result
Let Google itself catch up on chatbots too
Now the one in a tough spot is them
What if
For example there's a company, just hypothetically
In a fictional world
A company not only made a chatbot
But also marched forward triumphantly
Doing better and better
Really just ate up your search in one go
Completely didn't give you a chance to fight back
Then it would be very tough
Did the chatbot not eat up search
Because OpenAI didn't do it well
Or why
Or because it can't kill off search
I think
Both sides actually have reasons
That is first um
Current chatbot interaction methods
Actually won't completely eat up search
Because it's stronger than search
Like we said earliest just now
The one point it's stronger than search
Is that it has strong interactivity
You can follow up
And
It can help you condense some very complex information
This is where it's very strong
So this portion of usage scenarios
It will indeed steal people from search but
There are still some very stupid scenarios in search
Where you have a very simple thing
You don't want to waste this time
On a chatbot
Like I just
I just search buy rice
I search buy and it's done
Just
Do I have to ask ChatGPT
Do I have to ask which one is good
And it's still spinning there
Spinning for half a day
Then gives you a link
You click again
Then go to the webpage to buy
Right there's no need for that
So from actual usage
Its current form
Is not enough to completely eat up search
Right and
Of course from another perspective
It might not have reached the peak in the chatbot thing either
It really let Google catch up
Now it's not quite caught up yet
In terms of product
I think in terms of product it's not caught up
But in terms of model it has already caught up
But if you want investors to invest in OpenAI
They would say
When they placed their bet
They recognized clearly
OpenAI is actually a product company
Its moat is actually product and brand
Then from today's perspective
It seems Google hasn't been able to in this matter
Catch up
Can't say surpass OpenAI
Catch up to OpenAI
Right I think
This is actually
Anyway this is all from my perspective as an outsider
An observer's perspective
You're a commentator today
Hahaha
From an observer's perspective
I think Google has traditionally been a bit slow with products
Has always been relatively slow
And so
然后所以
Do you think OpenAI has an advantage when it comes to products?
I think it's possible.
Right.
And what's one thing Google is particularly good at?
Finding an extremely simple product form.
Everyone looks the same.
Then it just competes with you relentlessly on technology.
And you can't outcompete it.
Oh, right.
That's exactly what Google is good at.
Because search engines are exactly like that.
Search is a classic example.
Everyone has the same search box.
One button, but it just searches faster than you.
And more accurately than you.
There's nothing you can do about it.
Mm-hmm.
So that's why.
Like.
It feels like all along.
Google has been in this state of doing very well, but...
Wall Street never really bought into it.
Everyone always wondered where this company's moat really is.
There's no product ingenuity.
No retention mechanisms either.
But it has survived until now.
So what's the reason its technology is so good?
I think it's still about the people, right?
I think it's the culture.
It's said to be.
A place that particularly, particularly values.
In the past, it particularly valued engineers.
Later, it particularly valued research.
That's the kind of culture.
So it's very well suited for.
Products where technological capability spills over.
Capability-based products.
Right, if you look at it from this angle.
Then do you think OpenAI's position is secure?
Now?
I don't think anyone's position is secure right now.
Hahahaha, right.
I think the form of AI.
Still has a long way to go.
Mm-hmm.
We're not at any endgame yet.
That's the feeling about this.
Right.
It feels like back home there's already a bit of this sentiment.
Yeah, I don't get it.
Like, why don't I get it?
I'm really puzzled.
Like.
So back home, people think we're fighting over a super app.
A super app is zero-sum, right?
I think conditioned on the chatbot thing (taking the chatbot
as the condition to build on) that's the super app.
Then maybe there's something to fight over.
But the problem is.
Is this form the super app form?
What if someone else.
Comes out with a completely different form one day.
And your functionality becomes a subset.
Of that thing.
That's quite possible, right?
I don't think there's anything.
I don't see anything impossible.
Why wouldn't the chatbot be the ultimate form?
But after all these years, this is all we've seen.
Right, it's all just a chat box.
I think on this matter, I really don't have any.
Rational or quantitative criteria.
To explain it.
More like you just feel like this whole thing is stupid.
Like this model clearly has so many capabilities.
But the way we use it is a chatbot (Note: This video was recorded over 2 months ago, when the agent paradigm was not yet clear).
It just doesn't quite make sense.
You know what I mean, so.
We need a product manager.
To unlock the model's capabilities.
Hahaha.
Humans have only communicated with AI through chatbots until now.
That seems stupid to you, right?
It's stupid because.
Then what should we use to communicate with AI?
Haven't figured it out.
If I had figured it out, I'd already be doing it.
Hahahaha.
Hey, you didn't tell me.
What exactly changed inside Google.
To lead to what the outside world saw.
The rapid leap in model capabilities.
Right, like I just said, it's one thing.
I think the organization has more clarity now.
And.
Once the organization is clear.
Did the organization change?
Right.
Especially pre-training.
Has become very, very clear now.
That is who is responsible for what
And every point
Who is the responsible person at every node
These things are very clear
Was it chaotic before
It was very chaotic in the earliest days
I wasn't there in the earliest days
But according to colleagues
Based on colleagues' or people I knew's descriptions
It was still more chaotic before
Mm-hmm right right
And now
At least pre-training has also become very very clear
And plus
This Google
Has always had
This relatively strong technical background
And it does things relatively systematically
So I feel
Pre-training at Google
Is a very very controllable thing
Mm-hmm predictable thing
You can
You can know
The next generation won't be bad
Oh you might even know how good it will be
Through Anthropic's top-down management it also
Mm-hmm not bad
Then Google is this bottom-up
It's still bottom-up right
It's definitely more top-down than before
Compared to the earliest days
But compared to Anthropic
It's still more bottom-up
Like different cultures can both work
Right right
For model training
Right that's
I think big companies have big company ways
Startups have startup ways
So big companies are
You also just said
It's a completely different narrative
It's a different
Method, what is Google's method
Now I think Google more says
Like this kind of relatively deterministic thing
Like pre-training
Is already a relatively deterministic paradigm
Then maybe Google will be more like
Making it into an engineering project
Google's engineering management ability is very strong
So it can slowly do it well
Mm-hmm what is an engineering project
Engineering project means
You are actually
Actually very very
Very top-down organization
And very clear
What we need to do in the next stage
Then go do this thing
What nodes need to be handled in between
And even doing research is like
Having a very clear framework
Telling you how to
Verify whether your results are good or bad
Evaluate whether your results are good or bad
Right so this is
Something Google is very strong at
In any big engineering project in the past
So pre-training
Actually I think has now entered
Google's comfort zone
And
Post-training of course has more uncertainty
Then maybe post-training currently
Is still more bottom-up
Everyone can try more broadly
You say pre-train is also a kind of RL
Why do you say that
I think it's
It's hard to say from a pure technical perspective
Pre-train is pre-training
Or supervised learning
What is the essential difference between SFT and RL
Because pre-training and SFT
Of course pre-training and SFT are essentially not that different
That is
You just take the data you get
As your ground truth
Then you treat that as your expert
Treat that as your expert output
Then you align toward the distribution of that expert output
Reinforcement learning might be a broader level
One level, it's saying first this
This original output
Is also not a given expert
But something I produced myself
And among them there are good results
And also bad results
So you want good results to move closer to that
and bad results to move away from it, something like that
So in a sense
pre-training and SFT are a subset of reinforcement learning
But
these two things do, in this era
have their differences
Of course, for me
the biggest difference lies in the data
For pre-training data
what matters more is having a good distribution
The distribution needs to be broad enough, or aligned well enough
with the scope you want to cover
But data quality
doesn't need to be extremely high
But for post-training
it's the opposite
In terms of distribution, it may be much narrower
But for the data it does have
the quality requirements are very high
Yeah, right
So for now
for me
the most fundamental difference between the two
is still in the data distribution
rather than in algorithms or training paradigms
So how do different labs
organize these teams?
Are pre-training and post-training different?
Or are they the same?
Anthropic
and Google are pretty similar
Both of them
have one team for pre-training
and another team for post-training
OpenAI might be more chaotic
In the early days
initially they had three teams
They had pre-training
and they also had reinforcement learning
the Strawberry team
and they also had a post-training team
And my
I never worked there
but my understanding is
its post-training wasn't really
its RL team, Strawberry
and its post-training
are actually what other companies call post-training and product
Oh, so
they might have divided it in a different way
and sliced it up
They treat the later stages as product work
As part of it
their post-training is actually intertwined with product
they're building the product
Is it just that the name hasn't been updated?
Not entirely
Because
at most companies, the product team
doesn't really train models anymore
They mostly communicate the desired
traits
the model traits, to the team training the model
But it seems like their post-training
is in a sense its own product team
but it can also train models
Is that because
their understanding of product is that
people who train models should also build the product
Yeah, yeah, possibly
It could be a good thing
Yeah, but their org has also changed a lot since then
So
I don't know what their org looks like now
You guys have released several models recently
and I saw you were involved in all of them
Gemini 3 Deep Think
Gemini 3.1 Pro
Well, I think I can only say
that I was fortunate to be involved
Hahaha, yeah
Again, it all feels like collective work
How did you become such a public figure now
getting singled out and mentioned separately every time
I don't get it
I actually don't think it's great
Every time I see it
I feel like
how am I going to face my colleagues in the office tomorrow
Hahaha
Does it feel awkward?
At the office it's fine
I think my colleagues are just good people
Like
they probably don't care too much about these things
But honestly
I feel like every project I've been part of
whether at Google or at Anthropic
It would happen even without me
Would all happen the same
Effect wouldn't wouldn't wouldn't
Get worse
I am
I think everyone now is
Everyone is a surfer
Essentially it's a wave
Not you the surfer
Mm-hmm, is the wave AI
Right it's AI
This thing itself is this wave
It will move forward
Whether you surf this wave or not
This wave will crash on shore
Just that some people might surf this wave
Some people might be a bit late
Didn't catch the crest of the wave
Okay
You were fortunate to participate in these two projects
What
Mainly probably some some
Those small details in algorithmic design
Then we would
Discuss together
And
Some
Some things on the data side
But things on the data side
I think
Might have more impact on future work
Do these models have paradigm changes
Mm-hmm I don't think any
No change is big enough to
From not knowing how to do large-scale reinforcement learning
To large-scale reinforcement learning
That level of change
No change is big enough to that extent
There are definitely some small changes
Can you talk about these small changes
These new models
There are definitely some small changes
Recently I feel models are already numb
A bunch of domestic models
And many foreign models too
OpenAI you all
Mm-hmm domestic GLM, ByteDance
DeepSeek has been expected but hasn't released yet
Kimi can you highlight the key points for everyone
I think
In a sense
None are that worth paying attention to
Hey what are people competing over now
Feels like chaos
I think some things people are competing over
Actually looking at it now
In this era
Already not that important
Because of inertia from the past
Everyone would compete for first place on various Benchmarks
To prove their model's basic capability is strong
This thing
Actually by now it has reached
Public attention
Those Benchmarks are somewhat maxed out
Actually think about it, earliest everyone paid attention to SWE-bench
Randomly everyone hit 80-something
Fortunately no one exceeded 83
Because recently OpenAI just released a post saying they exceeded 83
Some of those problems are not well-defined
Fortunately no one exceeded it
Whoever exceeds it would be embarrassed
Anyway
And before everyone reasoned by finishing AIME then IMO
After IMO what
Can't think of RKGI and such
Benchmark then RKGI
Mm-hmm before Gemini 3
Everyone probably forgot the highest
At that time maybe level 10 or so
And everyone was like wow
Hard as climbing to heaven
Then Gemini 3 made it 30-something
Then Claude 4.5 or 4.6 became
4.6 should have become 60-something
Then Gemini 3 Deep Think hit 80-something
So this is also maxed out
So now it feels like
Just relying on hitting these publicly recognized model capabilities
Actually doesn't have much meaning anymore
And um
So from this perspective
I just
Essentially there aren't too many key points
Although everyone is releasing very fast
Mm-hmm
Releasing fast also shows
Actually this problem has become easy
For everyone
Everyone knows the know-how now
There are no secrets anymore
Right, right
It's still this, it's still that
It's still that same thing
The surfing theory, right
It's still this
The wave is moving forward
What's the next goal everyone might be looking for
What's the next paradigm-level change
Will there still be one
Ah, I think
The two things I just mentioned are
I think ML coding and long horizon, right
And these two are
I think, I think
Um
Yes, yes
I think it might be something that hasn't reached paradigm-level change
But I think it is
Something very valuable for Google
Because first of all, ML coding is
Because
Google itself is a major player in AI research
And it's also the most full-stack in AI research
That is
Not only does it have these model training parts
It also has hardware design
The part connecting hardware to models
If this entire system can be accelerated
Or better managed
That could be very valuable for this company
Long horizon goes without saying
Everyone knows
Everyone thinks it's very important
Right
So I think that might be, for me
Can't say it's paradigm-level
Definitely not at the paradigm level
But it's something I think is very valuable
That needs to be able to, within the next few months
Show some light at the end of the tunnel, and um
I think paradigm-level
Might still be those more uncertain things
Like multimodal generation, that kind of thing
I think there might be a hero
Or a group of heroes
Haha, and um, right
That kind of thing might have some
Um, also talked about a lot is continue learning（持续学习）
What about world models
I think continue learning and this kind of long horizon
Just said there's no fundamental difference with long horizon
Because, um
Because people used to think these two things were very different
It's because
Continue learning changes some of the model's weights
And when you do this kind of
For example, like open
Open source
Everyone does a lot of this kind of
This kind of context management（上下文管理）
Doesn't change model weights
But actually, if you think about it, there's no fundamental difference between these two things
Because those tokens in the context
Their own KV cache is also a kind of weight, isn't it
So
You think between these two approaches, which one can
Which one will be more useful
More useful in the long run
I think it's unclear
But essentially they
Are both for doing what I just mentioned, long horizon
This type of thing
And world models
Ten thousand people have ten thousand world models
What does that mean? The definition isn't clear
That is
First of all, I don't know what a world model is
And secondly
When everyone talks about the world models they're building
They might be talking about different things
For example, the world model that Gemini builds might be different from
For example, like
Fei-Fei Li
The world models they're building are not the same thing
Um, sigh
Describe the difference
I don't particularly understand what labs like Fei-Fei Li's
What these labs are doing
What it's actually like
But, um
Gemini's world model is more of a
It's a kind of end-to-end（端到端） level of training
The result it wants is that I can, for example
For example, video generation
Is that given a description
Then generate a video
But the result it wants to achieve is
Not only can I generate a video
I am able to generate a scenario
What is a scenario
Scenario means I generate
The state at this moment
And then I can also give it a condition
A condition
This condition is that under this state I did some
What kind of
Action
And then its next moment state
Will become a function of my previous moment
State and action
And it's end-to-end training this kind of capability
Right so this might be one solution
And I
First I don't know
What result everyone ultimately wants
And I also don't know what everyone's
Definition of their own world model is
So I think it's more of an exploratory state
We haven't talked about one organization just now, xAI
We just talked about Anthropic
Talked about OpenAI
Talked about DeepMind
What about xAI
xAI I don't understand haha
As a commentator let's talk about it
Why are they so turbulent recently
I think they've always been quite turbulent
Hahaha why so turbulent recently
I don't know either
And
Actually I don't have that much contact with xAI
Some people I contacted have also left now
Actually I don't know what happened to them
Hahaha
When you were talking about Anthropic just now
You said
The technical number one being able to make bets
Is very important
Then at Google who is this number one
Who is this hero
I think heroes
Might be different people at different stages
Mm-hmm but behind every hero there is one person
Sergey Brin
Google's cofounder
Oh right
I think ultimately many many big decisions
Might not be decided by him on how to do them
But in the end he has to be the one to make the final call
Mm-hmm even now
What about Demis Hassabis
I think the person who appears more on the front lines
Is Koray Kavukcuoglu
Right
Yes
DeepMind CTO
And he's now also that Google SVP
Oh what is Demis responsible for
I think Demis might manage more of those
Things leaning toward science
Like for example drug design
Isomorphic Labs and such things
Right right right
Oh Gemini
He doesn't manage much
At least from my perspective
The person I see more is Koray
Of course it's possible that
Company management matters
Actually there are many parts I can't see
Then I'm not clear about that
You also mentioned AI is a whole system
Mm-hmm
What understanding do you have about how to systematically do AI
Now
After these two years of your work
Several aspects
One aspect is from the whole system perspective
It needs a relatively scientific attitude
That you need to clearly understand like Scaling Law
You need to clearly understand
What assumptions you have made
And when I make a change
What factors are actually related to it
What factors are not related
Right
And this is from the organizational perspective
From the people's perspective
Actually requires people to be very reliable
Requires very responsible people
Actually every system
Every evaluation framework
Is very easily hacked
Because you can always do something
To make your metrics look very good
But a trustworthy
Or down-to-earth person
He would actually think
If the thing he did works well
Is it really
For example effective at large scales
Did I miss some factors in between
Right
Actually doing things systematically
Sounds like one sentence
But actually doing it is very complex
There are many details
Many resistances
It actually goes against human nature
Oh
Because every individual's human nature
Might be to make their own things
Show up better
But for a company or an organization
The most beneficial thing
Is to make the entire company's system
Very solid systematically
This is actually the best for you personally
Because once this system is solid
You can leverage this system
To produce more output
But the bad thing is
This system will make your individual heroism
Not shine
But you can rest assured that others' individual heroism
Also won't shine
But if you are in a system
Where individual heroism can shine
Then this system might
Not be particularly stable
Because one person leaving
Might cause the entire thing to collapse
For example like OpenAI
You say you love to challenge difficult things
But this industry seems to require
Doing simple things well repeatedly
Actually
I think the so-called simple things
Doing them well repeatedly
Is actually a very difficult thing
Because human nature doesn't like
Doing repetitive things
Because the most difficult thing in this industry
Is actually doing simple things cleanly
Why
Because everyone can do simple things
If you can't do them cleaner than others
需要研究员自己对于这个系统
怎么运作
有一个好的理解
然后以及对公司负责任才能做到
否则就是你很容易做到一件事
就是
你可能比如说你在考虑training的时候
是比别人好的
但你考虑training加sampling时候比别人差
你总可以选择你只是有training
但这就很糟糕
对
所以这个就是既需要你个人的负责任
又需要说组织所建立的这个体系里
能够能尽量的发现这些
有意的或者无意的
这种边界的事情
但是你作为个体的话
你不知道怎么样是对全局最好的呀
其实是需要
我觉得如果一个研究员做不到
对全局去考虑的话
他就不是一个好的研究员
在现在这个时代
嗯 就是这个
我觉得这个
和你就是在学术界做research
是很不一样的事
哦
因为在学术界做research
本质上是一个人吃饱
全家不愁的状态
这我为我的项目负责对吧
我为我的可重复性负责
但是在一个公司里
你其实更多的时候是
我得为这个公司负责
这是两种完全不一样的心态
那你这种自觉性从哪里来的
不知道哈哈哈哈哈
我觉得我可能就是拉不下脸
哈哈哈
拉不下脸是什么
就是
你对一个公司负责任
是你和这个公司的契约的一部分
其实我觉得没什么道理不这么做
这么做是没有原因的
所以这个人英雄主义会破坏这种整体性
我觉得
If you're just doing it for personal heroism
and acting on that basis
it's very likely to undermine the bigger picture
Of course, in reality you might be very capable
and you actually become a hero
that's also possible
Since you've also been through two organizations
what kind of organization do you think is better at fostering intelligence
in this era
I think
this is actually a
very controversial topic
I mean
as we were just discussing
different organizations
some tend to be more top-down
some more bottom-up
so the natural question is
for example
which of these two types fosters more innovation
The traditional view was
bottom-up was a necessary condition for fostering innovation
because everyone needs freedom, right
only with freedom can there be innovation
But purely bottom-up
you find it doesn't actually work either
because it just becomes chaotic
That's what Google was like before
Was it?
Yes
At least in my impression
from what I understand, that's how it was
It was just chaotic
People didn't even know
what the point of what I was doing was
That might not be great either
So you probably need someone
or a small group
who can blend these two approaches somewhat
Mm-hmm
That's why I think
whether an organization runs well or not
it looks like an organizational issue
but ultimately it comes down to the tech leader
Mm-hmm
It's about whether this tech leader has the qualities
to keep the organization running stably
Because the optimal state
is often the most unstable one
It easily collapses toward a worse state
Right, so you need a leader to control that
So do you think it should always be the tech leader doing this
rather than the CEO
Well of course every company's CEO
may have different responsibilities
But there needs to be a leader
I think you need at least one leader
who has two qualities
to be able to do this
One quality is that they can fight fires themselves
It's not just talking about what to do
What to do
but rather when something really runs into trouble
they can step in and lead the team
to solve the problem
Of course most of the time
a leader probably
won't have time to do this
But at least they have the capability
The second important quality
is that they need to understand others
Even if it's something
that they wouldn't do themselves
they can understand
why what others are doing matters
They can tolerate and accommodate others
That might be another quality
What do you think about Google's TPU
In what ways does it outperform GPUs
What are its weaknesses
I think
From a purely hardware perspective
it's hard to say which hardware is truly better or worse
especially at this kind of large-scale commercial deployment
Because fundamentally
GPUs and TPUs
In terms of usage
the biggest difference, setting aside
the hardware differences
in terms of usage
the biggest difference is
GPUs have a better open-source ecosystem
TPUs don't
But this actually isn't an issue at large-scale commercial deployment
It's not a problem
Because for example, Google itself uses TPUs
so naturally they'll spend time building
this infrastructure
And infrastructure is
For example, if you're only running a thousand cards
it could be a heavy burden
But if you're running a cluster of hundreds of thousands of cards
then building out the infrastructure
isn't really that big of a deal
And in practice
So basically
when it comes to large-scale commercial deployment
neither one is inherently superior or inferior
But these two do
have some differences in design philosophy
Take GPUs, for example
At least for the more recent GPU generations
I haven't used them much
Like the Hopper generation of GPUs
The H-series GPUs
The design philosophy is that
inside one pod (node)
there might not be that many cards
say, just eight cards
and these eight cards can all interconnect with one another
NVLink (NVIDIA's high-speed interconnect bus) is extremely fast
So within one pod, there's basically
no communication bandwidth bottleneck (insufficient bandwidth between GPUs)
But TPUs take the opposite approach
It means that
they've abandoned pairwise interconnection between cards
but they try as much as possible to
fit as many cards as possible
into one big rack
It has this kind of
3D Torus design (3D Torus topology design)
So each card
only connects to its three nearest neighbors in three directions
but the entire cluster can be connected into one big
Torus
And if your compilers (compilers)
or your sharding (data sharding strategy)
logic is written well enough
you can take advantage of this architecture
Effectively speaking
you get more memory capacity
and also reduce a lot of communication bounds
What's the downside?
I think one downside is that
compared to GPUs, it definitely
at least at a small scale
is more
of a rigid structure
So its ease of use
or its general versatility might not be as strong
Recently many neo labs have emerged in Silicon Valley
What do you think of this trend?
Why are they all leaving
jumping ship from these big model companies
to start neo labs
I don't really get it
Haha, my feeling is that
the vast majority of neo labs will die. And
Well, I think
some labs genuinely have good people
And some labs
might actually be starting to do some real work
For example, like Thinking Machines
is still delivering some new things
But some neo labs
Please bleep out the names
Haha, like XXX, that XXX
I have absolutely no idea what they're trying to do
And
These two have actually been away from the field for a long time
I think in 2026
China will place a lot of emphasis on the consumer-side narrative
Who becomes that super app
What do you think?
Do you think this
It seems like nobody in Silicon Valley talks about this
Right, because American enterprise is just...
It's companies
Or rather, the productivity software market is just too big
and the profit margins are too high
So for the US
there was basically only ChatGPT doing consumer before
and there wasn't much money in it
Not much profit
So
now everyone will probably focus first on
productivity software
or enterprise
And
So the trends in China and the US have already diverged
I think
Not just AI
The entire internet industry in the past was like this too
It was all different
What China is really strong at is the consumer side
It can come up with, like
really, really complex product features
or structures
and in a way that seems very indirect to you
In a very unnatural way
to snowball that profit
For example
What do I mean by indirect?
(laughs)
Like, take something like Douyin (TikTok)
It's not like
you watch a video
and I charge you 20 cents per video, right?
It says you can watch videos for free
but I can quietly slip in ads
I can quietly do live streaming
I can quietly do e-commerce
But that doesn't work for productivity software
Productivity software is very straightforward
Like, I help you write code
My cost is 150 a month
I sell it to you for 200, I make 50
It's that straightforward
Mm
Yeah, I think what the US has shown in the past
is that with these very straightforward products
it can push technology to the extreme
But there's never been
a product that felt so sophisticated
that you can't live without it
yet you don't feel like it's taking your money
but it's actually making money from you
Hearing you say that, I suddenly feel Meta should just copy ByteDance
Yeah, but I don't think Meta is as strong as ByteDance
Because Meta can't find its own niche either
And
there's no American company doing this
No one has found the niche that Doubao occupies
Then Meta should just copy Doubao
It doesn't need such strong model capabilities either
But I still think the Americans making products
fundamentally, the people doing consumer products aren't good enough
Far behind China
This is the accumulation of the past decade, right?
Yeah
Mm
Because the positive feedback loop in the US over the past decade
all came from doing B2B
A lot of enterprise stuff
Or it's just too easy to make money in the US
Mm
When it's too easy to make money
you won't rack your brains over how to make money
Hey
Haven't a lot of people come to chat with you?
Any interesting people?
Oh, well
A lot of people from China came
Tech companies
I think they're all pretty interesting
And I did find that Chinese people doing products
probably think in more sophisticated ways
More sophisticated
Yeah, they think more...
Their thought process is more convoluted
Yeah, it's a completely different style from the US
America is like
As I just said about America
It's like
you build something and sell it directly
Yeah, it's simple
That's how it is
You just need this capability
Once you have it, you just need to be cheaper than others
Then I can earn more than you
And you can't do anything about it
Okay
What about China?
China seems to be all about this pattern
Not making money at first
But once it starts making money
you can't stop it
It's just that
it can really form that
that self-sustaining
that loop
When it really gets that flywheel spinning
you can't break in anymore
Do you think American companies
understand ByteDance now?
My feeling is no
Not yet
It's already so big
Oh, you mean whether they take it seriously?
Of course they do
Everyone definitely knows
ByteDance is a severely undervalued
In terms of its valuation
It's a severely undervalued company
I think that's very clear to everyone
And
I think it's also clear
that in the consumer market
On this end, I actually think
No American company can compete with ByteDance
But after all it's a Chinese company
At least in terms of public perception
After all it's a Chinese company
So do people understand it
I don't think people understand it
But look at Meta
It's also actively poaching people from ByteDance
Mm-hmm, do you have any idols in the AI industry
Or people you admire
Although you've been in the AI industry for a short time
No no no, nothing
I just feel
When I came to this industry
The era of individual heroism had already passed
So there are no heroes
Sometimes you even think old-era heroes are a bit stupid
Ah, right
So really there's nothing
Who do you think is quite stupid
Let's not talk about this
No comment hahahaha
Right, I think it's
Different from doing physics
I think when doing physics
There were still some
People I think really much smarter than me
Like me
When I was doing my PhD my young advisor was
I think he, Douglas Stanford
I think he's just much smarter than me
I think he
Maybe also seeing him
Made me feel in that field
Not very useful
With him around what do they need me for
Right, haha
You came to AI to do a dimensionality reduction attack right
Not a dimensionality reduction attack
But anyway it feels like AI this thing
Doesn't really need brains
Really doesn't need brains
Then what does it need
I think this
The most important trait in this industry
Is being reliable
Doing things carefully
And being responsible for what you do
This is the most important trait
You say how much brains those things need, I think
They're all things undergraduates can do
But you say AI has no individual heroism
Now an AI researcher is priced so high
Like a star player transfer
I don't know if it's a good thing or bad thing
For me personally
Of course I'm very happy
I benefit from this
Right hehehe
But um
Actually speaking
I don't know if this thing
Is a good thing
Why do you think the price has become so high
I think maybe on one hand
Everyone thinks this thing is scarce
But actually it might not be that scarce
Because training a person
Although this thing isn't that hard
But training a person requires an environment
You need to have that opportunity to be exposed to this thing
To learn this thing
Without that opportunity
No matter how smart you are it's useless
Maybe in the past people who could encounter that opportunity
Weren't that many
So in the market it might be relatively scarce
From this perspective
Mm-hmm
But I think another aspect is also
Maybe the hype about people is a bit excessive
Right
Really like to mythologize individuals
Now
Right I think
Really
Just say it again
This is a collectivist thing haha
Then many people are also very curious
Because
Maybe many companies also want to recruit AI people
Then you think the most important thing is still being reliable
What metrics are there for this
How can you quickly judge whether a person is reliable
Whether they do things carefully
Everyone has some methods they use to measure
I of course also have some of my own tricks
It's just that I
I used to design an interview question
Let me briefly explain it
This
It shouldnt be confidential
So I should be able to talk about it
Um
So the interview question is actually quite simple
I need this person to, within 24 hours,
complete a reinforcement learning project
from scratch
They have to choose on their own
what kind of model
I tell them what resources are available
and they choose what model to use
what data to use
what algorithm to use
and train the model
Within 24 hours
I give them 24 hours to get this done
And after the 24 hours are up
they'll have a one-hour discussion with me
So this thing
isn't that hard in the AI era
Without AI
this would be impossible
No one could do it in 24 hours
But with AI, it's actually quite easy
Because AI can do the whole thing for you
But why still do this?
There are two reasons
There are many reasons
Among them
Two reasons why it was designed this way
One reason is that I think in this era, evaluating someone
evaluating someone
like whether they write good code
is actually useless
Because most people don't need to write code themselves anymore
What's more important is
whether they can effectively leverage AI
So that's one aspect of evaluating this
The second aspect is that there's a trap here
If you let AI do everything
but you don't really try to understand
what AI did for you
you'll be exposed during that one-hour discussion
That's a
That's where people fail
So the other thing this tests
is whether you've truly formed a collaboration with AI
Or if you just completely handed it off
That's something I personally value very much
That also
reflects whether this person
is someone reliable
Of course, this
The design of this question itself
also has some rather dark cleverness to it
Like why it was designed as 24 hours
is to see how much this person values this opportunity
Can they stay up all night
Right, hahaha
If they're willing to pull an all-nighter
they can survive these 24 hours
If they can't make it
then it just means
they probably don't value this opportunity that much
Haha
So for people younger than you
Do you think AI is still
a blue ocean
a place with lots of opportunities
I think purely working on language models
is no longer a blue ocean
I think it's too late — the last train has already left
The last train has already left
Which last train is that?
I feel like I got in on that last train
And there might have been some people after I got in
some new people
But I think
they won't have the opportunity
to encounter such good opportunities
Like being able to
do something in a relatively small team
Chances to encounter such opportunities will be rare
Right, and then
But I think AI
is a very vast field
Language models are just a tiny, tiny part of it
A very small part
There are many other things
Like the multimodal generation we just mentioned
There may still be many opportunities there
Robotics probably has even more opportunities
And even more extreme, there's
like whether you can use AI
to help with real scientific problems
Like helping with
quantum control and things like that
Then it might be more blue ocean
Those are all blue sky things
Right so
I think for
People young enough
Maybe doing the hottest thing right now
Is not the right choice
Doing things no one has done now
Might be more of a good choice
Right
How will you develop in the future
Will you be at Google for a long time
I think probably not
Hahahaha
Saying this so publicly
I think probably not
I think I will still try to challenge myself
Right and
Need to torture myself
Right need to torture myself
But
I just might need to find something
Worth torturing myself for
If AI is not fundamentally difficult
Won't you find it boring
Where is your challenge
Although it's not difficult
But knowing and not knowing
There is still a gap
From completely not knowing the details
To slowly understanding the details
Understanding how it works and such
These things
I think still require spending time and effort
And after you understand
I think this thing will also be helpful for your future
Like whether you do product related
Or develop toward other AI directions
I think all
In the long term
Will be helpful
Where do you want to develop in the future
I think anything is possible
Haha haven't figured out how to torture myself
You probably won't jump to another big company again
Probably not
Mm-hmm
What differences do you feel between what you learned at Anthropic
And what you learned at Google DeepMind
I think they're quite different
I think Anthropic
Is where you can understand one thing
One line, language model
Every aspect of this line very thoroughly
It gives you that opportunity
And at Google
It's more horizontal
It has many different aspects
Many different people
And you can also see different perspectives
Also see different research directions
You can see all of them
Right
Anthropic is because it bets firmly enough
So you can understand more vertically
Right
Have you thought about using AI to solve physics problems
(Your theoretical physics) Someone is doing it
So I don't think I need to do it haha
You don't have essential interest in this
I think this thing
First
Currently it's not the highest priority for me
I think if one day
I think
I solve the highest priority thing on my hands
And haven't found anything else to do
I might go do this thing
What is your highest priority now
My highest priority now is
To push the two things I just mentioned
Oh ML coding and long horizon
To at least a
Where colleagues can
Push it to a relatively
I think relatively stable state
That I think is my highest priority
Of course there might be other priorities later
But
Using AI to do physics
I think is something
Many people are already trying to do
One more of me is not too many
One less of me is not too few
Might as well let others do it first
Do you have any physicists you particularly admire
Not really
Yes, but there are quite a few
Don't know where to start
Hahahaha
Physicists yes
AI scientists
No
But this is related to a person's growth experience
I think
Like
An adult finds it hard to truly worship a person
A child might
Who have you worshipped
I think in physics
Actually there are many who are really quite strong
But those everyone talks about
People from 100 years ago let's not talk about
Like Einstein
Heisenberg and such let's not talk about
And including everyone later knows
Like Frank Yang
Chen-Ning Yang and such let's also not talk about
And
Like when I was doing topology before
Actually there was someone who later also won the Nobel Prize
That Haldane
You'll find these people
Have some abnormal foresight
They seemed out of place in their era
But look at Haldane
When he first did Haldane model and these fractional
Quantum Hall effect related things
It was decades away from when everyone finally figured out these topological states
Many decades later
Mm-hmm
At that time he could feel this thing was important
And kept pushing this thing himself
I think this is not easy
Of course I think
If you really want to find a similar person in AI
I think maybe Geoffrey Hinton
When everyone felt this thing
Was optional or not that certain
He kept working in this direction
Then I think
This might be a hero-level figure
After him
AI after that
I think
I think there might also be some heroic collectives
Like for example Transformer
Noam
And those
That
Ashish
Niki and them
That might be a heroic collective
You said something that made a very deep impression on me
I don't have any mentors in this industry
Don't have any old friends
I can criticize whoever I want
This might be the benefit of not doing AI
Hahaha the benefit of not coming from AI
Right, like
Really have no burden
No old-timer is your relative
So if you think he's stupid
He is stupid
Can just say he's stupid directly
It doesn't matter
Were you like this before too
I think I was quite restrained when I was a student
Oh
But later I found restraint useless
No benefit to myself
No benefit to others either
Better to be more direct
Expressing your own ideas is the most critical thing
I think directly expressing your own ideas
Is something where in the short term people will definitely hate you
But in the long term everyone will appreciate
Who have you heard speaking particularly stupidly recently
Bleep out that name
Thank you
I think XXX has always been quite stupid, haha
And consistently stupid, haha
Could he possibly be the right person
I think what he says
In Pauli's words is not even wrong
Because it's not well-defined
It's hard to say whether what he says is right or wrong
Right, like one day
Maybe a different paradigm happens
He can jump out and say hey
I said this this this this back then
But then you discover
Maybe if the paradigm were another state
He could also say the same thing
This is why I hate this kind of very vague
Very vague people
Because a thing being vague is meaningless
Why do you think he speaks very vaguely
No correct definition
Like
It's kind of ambiguous
If it has a proper definition
I can explain why it's properly defined
But if it doesn't have a proper definition
I have no way to explain
Why it isn't properly defined
Because it really isn't properly defined
Hahaha
What about XXX
I think at least
I think
XXX is still a well-defined thing
Like, it's trying to do XXX
And their approach might lean more toward this
More traditional kind of
This neural network model approach
Rather than a more end-to-end approach
I think at least it's well-defined
As for whether it's right or wrong
I think that's something the future will test
Most old geezers are actually fine
I think
I think when people get old
They don't necessarily turn into old geezers
When people get old, they split into two types
One type is the venerable elder
They might stop nitpicking so much
And actually put effort into mentoring young people
The other type is the old geezer
They don't know what they're talking about
Yet love to nitpick and boss people around
Yeah, so getting old doesn't necessarily make you an old geezer
Hey, who got you all riled up
I don't even know who got me riled up
But I've definitely met plenty of old geezers
Hahaha
When did you change
Like, becoming so direct when you speak
You stopped holding back—you've always thought this way
But you didn't say it
I think in the past I might have been pretty direct too
But not this direct
But after getting into AI, I became even more direct
So it's like nothing holding you back, right
One, there's nothing holding me back
Two, this field is objective enough
Like
You don't really have to worry too much
About offending people with your opinions
As long as your views are internally consistent
Like, you have a coherent framework for your views
You're not just randomly trashing people
That would definitely offend people
You have your own understanding of things
I think people will actually respect you for it
Because ultimately, how well you do in this field
Is judged by objective standards
Every guest we have recommends a life-changing book
It has to be a book that genuinely had a major impact on you
What book would you say
This is the hardest question of the day
I feel like you're overestimating my cultural sophistication
Hahahahaha
Honestly, I don't really have a life-changing book
Okay, I read a book recently
Recently
Last time Ji Yichao mentioned 'The Line Puppy'
The book I recently read is Yukawa's autobiography
Hideki Yukawa's (1949 Nobel Prize in Physics winner) autobiography
'Tabibito' (The Traveler)
And then
If I had to say, books that left an impression
First of all, I genuinely don't like reading
I feel like I'm not very well-read
And the books I read
Other than professional ones
All feel like leisure reading to me
Like Yukawa's autobiography
It's essentially leisure reading too
But I found it quite interesting
Like
You get to see
A scientist who later seemed so successful
Struggling in his youth
Very authentic
And then maybe some other leisure reads
Like novels and stuff
There's a novel I really like
'From the New World'—it's a Japanese novel
Yeah, if you really force me to recommend some leisure reading
I could recommend that one
Have you watched any movies or anything lately
TV shows, or played any games
Nothing at all
Hahaha
A favorite food from anywhere in the world
Sushi, probably
A favorite place anywhere in the world
I—I think if you really force me to choose
I'd probably choose Hawaii
Because I really love the ocean
Yeah, but it's hard to say for sure
Because after I visit more coastal places
I might have a new favorite
Hahaha
Something not many people know
But probably should
Don't trust old timers, does that count? Hahaha
Have you ever been superstitious?
Hmm
I
I haven't, fundamentally
But I think
Sometimes superstition can be a way to comfort yourself
I meant, have you ever been superstitious about old timers?
Oh, superstitious about old timers
Never?
Really, never
But I probably didn't hate old timers this much before
Then I started hating them more and more
Why?
Maybe it's just that
When you develop more judgment of your own
Stupid people just look even stupider
But they haven't hurt you
So why hate them?
It's just stupidity intolerance
Everyone has stupidity intolerance
Hey, what's your MBTI?
No idea
Why has there been, in recent years,
I mean, among young people
Toward older people
Such an unfriendly term emerging?
Where does it come from?
No idea
No, no, no
Haven't looked into it
Could ask Gemini
Have it do a Deep Research
See where the term "laodeng" comes from
So what are the papers that have influenced AI progress the most, in your mind?
Sequence-to-sequence is one
And then that
I think language models
At the peak of the feature engineering era
And then
Scaling Laws is one
The one by Jared Kaplan
Their Scaling Laws paper at OpenAI is also one
It's a paper that introduced this systematic research methodology
Into the field
A paper
Of course, the actual methods in Scaling Laws
May not have been exactly right
But it was the first
To introduce this idea
I think that's crucial
Based on your current understanding
What's a key important bet?
Long horizon (long-horizon tasks)
Hahaha
Our studio is called Language is World Studio
When you first heard this name
What were you thinking?
I think this name is a bit...
Too normal, too mediocre
Hahahaha, fair enough, hahahaha
I think this name is something that
Maybe ten years ago
Was a very unique perspective
But now there's just too much consensus
I think ten years ago it really was
Maybe it's been more than ten years now
Sorry, I feel like I'm getting old too
Maybe it's been more than ten years
Like around 2014, 2015
Everyone thought vision was the most important thing
Back then
I think realizing
That language is an important carrier of intelligence
Was probably something different
But I don't think our name
Was meant in an AI context
Hmm
Hahaha
Well then that's worth deep thought, hahaha